also important to keep in mind
don't i look so cute now that i cut a
bang right here
you got personality
yeah profile it fixes everything why do
i have a bigger building than y'all
oh that's a city you should change it oh
why did you yeah why did you put
yourself there that's stupid yeah pick
another spot you want to pick a
different spot okay
can you
again
count again if you count the dots this
is a good spot it looked like a lot of
dots so i was like all right this is a
good spot this far right here yeah
so
put this as well okay so it's just
probability dude so you got a six a five
and a four think about how many times
those things can get rolled
okay three different ways a four can get
rolled four different ways a five can
get rolled in six different ways the six
can get rolled i have a different
strategy don't pay attention to me
all right buddy
big old mr different strategy
what are you trying to do dude
i'm trying to get one of these uh
supports one of these longest roads
well let's go for it it's like a new
house a long road over here dude you
can't get them all it's not pokemon
that's true that was my strategy
yeah can i try again yeah redemption
round two you're doing it again
okay leverage
you find a point and you squeeze really
hard
okay
it's really just all on my neck
here we go you know whatever you were
doing before probably works just don't
yeah just whatever feels good you know
yeah that's what i was doing you don't
tell me i was doing wrong
yeah
we berated you to submit but it feels
good no it doesn't
what are you some kind of like the worse
off a table is the more bougie at this
point
this table is probably the worst
it's like sandpaper
it's like sandpaper if it wasn't present
at all in wood making
it's kind of disgusting too and but but
yet you know that it was expensive it's
very porous you know it's like what else
is in these little crevices yeah there's
like you can't clean this properly
i brought some pedialyte
oh yeah how about it i brought two balls
um
they're great flavored too like the soju
i would love one man thank you so much i
should have bought great soju from that
place that was good oh that was
incredible
incredible dude thanks man
that's from my country
oh yeah brother
hell yeah brother i still want to go
visit like
we've all put two cities on right here
no that's just me that was christy's
turn again this actually does feel
really good
don't make noises
grunting over here
that's my drunken grandma wait if i if i
later want to make a house it has to
always be two houses
i like to express
my emotions
through my grunts wait did i get skipped
no it goes opposite now oh so now you're
up but you can find another
but now you're going to put another city
in there right now
right okay so it goes this way and then
it goes back
oh i'm gonna have to i'm gonna need wood
yeah the woods are always they're
they're in bad spots
y'all need to figure out about wood
yo nobody has wood right now don't even
dare only hans has woods
making a decision right now or is this
legit no i'm in there i'm in wood but uh
you invest in wood
i'm on wood
damn wood
i was like are you trying to point me in
the right direction
i mean so here's a this is a nine and a
five and a wood right there
i mean i'm gonna trust you so town now
you guys said no no this is it
you're not gonna do this until you buy
it
and you have to buy it you can't even
buy a house
this is a good spot for wood a lot of
people need wood
okay cheat sheet let's go
you said this by christy right that was
christine
christie
[Music]
who did that who green
who's christina christina mariana
christina yeah of comedy she's not
blonde she's brunette
what do you think of blonde and brunette
r blonde is like blonde hair like me
yeah she has blonde hair i mean her
birth was italian so she has brown hair
but she has made it blonde just like
bianca and everybody else's pot she's
bianca is not a real blonde italian
prado
wait what
so who's the only people that are
belongs
you're a real blonde
yeah dude
my family worked hard for this
looks like
she's a real boy
[Music]
you know they get a bad rep however
they were like one of the first
societies to introduce divorce
and most of the time they allowed women
to be able to do that and they had a lot
of pro-women's very progressive yeah
they were actually very brutal
they also actually found america first
uh happy leave eric someday that's very
true it's wonderful
when is that day i don't know
in columbus every day but on america
columbus set foot on south america right
uh
in caribbeans yeah yeah it wasn't north
america though or south america or
central yeah that's right it was a
caribbean that's right
i knew it wasn't the [ __ ] lies we
were told as children
they're not good
usually they're like teaching you about
slavery you're in the back like go
figure
so get the resources from your second
settlement wherever you put that down
oh [ __ ] i'm guessing wood
well whatever you put your
the second second so livestock the three
wood and uh what is history
yeah what is the old cheaper
you think it's all about you dude you
keep running into my hand
let the games begin
what is this rock
that is brilliant
seven to start the game
i once rolled 77 sevens
what's gonna [ __ ] over hans the most
that's how you win right yeah yeah we
all need to attack on that's what we
were doing last time when below me and
brad and all of a sudden
they switched up and started
giving up on me
i thought this was alcohol
no i'm not gonna drink this sorry i
thought it was gonna be a white cloth
you're gonna be educating jacksonville i
don't wanna yeah this is gonna be a
panic attack
throw in the fridge or something in the
refrigerator okay i'll say i'll just
save it at least it's liquid gold yeah i
literally that was so stupid
do you feel good at least did it wake
you up drink just about your senses
yeah
her knots are forming back and forth
yeah does anybody want this back
yeah
all right
i'll pass the code stick
all right let me see a card
more brick for gareth oh buildings
oh you want me to show you or you're
going to show me no you show me because
i can show you all my
chris is pretty good at downward dog i
do i do like yoga stuff every single
morning because i sleep in my car
so i have to like read
cons what the [ __ ] is it
is there a place you do it or is it just
want me to do it show you now
whenever it's convenient you know
whatever it's your turn again get the
rod back
in the sharing rod the sharing right
sharing is what you have to say
are you done
uh
well i got distracted sorry
i am done yeah i'm gonna hold these bad
boys for a minute
that's the dies
okay
nine let's go
and it's like if i have a nine on here
then i yeah now you get the resource for
the nines
i'm going to get a stone
oh even though my house isn't over here
i get that no no no only if your house
is over there oh so red and orange so i
don't think i have any numbers are you
blue or red you have a red you're you're
blue you know christie's red yeah
christine did you get your card
you get a sheep
you're unknown oh so
come visit me dude
so who did you hear about the dallas
trip from
i saw it on instagram
you talking about uh what
uh someone said we need sam kuiper back
well i'm here baby
i'm glad that you don't think that i
[ __ ] up the things with the women i i
don't think it helped but i think she
texted me tonight today yeah maybe we
were just overthinking it you know yeah
yeah how many how many prospects did you
have
i had one heavy prospect okay i was
prospect i was a prospector she was very
nice and good looking yeah that was very
good we appraised it was it the same
person it's like after the first night
you posted a picture of kissing somebody
that was a different person that's his
game yeah that works for him though i
think how about
and you know you can edit your comment
but then
wait
it was that i think it's a good idea for
you to do like for uh
what is it called like a pictures after
the show yeah meet and greet oh we kind
of do it's a with a with the hans i
kissed hans sure and then they kiss you
whose turn is this shirt yeah i'm
guessing that's probably mine
but
what are you going to do are you done
bucks perpetrator in your turn can you
build anything no it's like if they kind
of
do you want to do anything yeah if you
have that that's a really good call
always a development card so you think
roads yeah might be a waste some guys if
you have a plan for them then it is not
a waste but if you don't then i would
say conserve your cards and move on okay
i hear you and uh
i'm gonna do something and i'm gonna
hope for the best all right
if i read these
what are you gonna do
so you can only put a city down
over
a settlement so you have to like take
your settlement away just i was talking
you should build like here or here i
mean i guess you can build there that's
fine decent okay and then i'll return
these in and move the next person one
what did you roll
so below is getting laid right now yeah
i think so i mean
all right buddy you go get that
go get that [ __ ]
yeah yeehaw forest is the ultimate
wingman
whose force oh forest
forest was great because he just talks
over everything he forces this old gay
guy whose house we stayed at in dallas
and he was just like goes off his tour
though was probably one of the best wing
manish things he did it yeah it's
interesting and it holds good
conversation and creating
non-threatening yes i did feel bad about
keeping up an 80 year old man until four
in the morning
uh that was a little bit much i thought
i was like dude this is kind of [ __ ]
he's a grown old old man yeah he loved
it he didn't choose when i take a
development card i thought he gave him
life or do i need to win
uh you have to
wait right you have to wait to use the
development yeah he said he had a lot of
fun great he did honestly he told me
that you said foie gras
no i did not say foie gras what he said
he had a lot of what fun
you only like her instagram comment all
over he only snapped
hey guys does anybody want to trade
yes i need uh wood does anybody have
wood i'll show you one wood for a brick
go
go fish bro at the end of the day this
is yeah
you want to do that again uh no
[Music]
the whole conversation didn't have
anything to do with the girls
i had to think about it more or less i
think the more you told me i gotta wait
for or if you want so the girls were
there and you were fighting with him
yeah i just had to think about it more
you know
i gotta sleep on it a little bit yeah no
smells great girls don't like that do
you like to trade you're trying to trade
do you have a sheet that's usually what
i'm just telling you yeah i don't know
what happened well i don't like it what
do you want to trade don't like it
yeah so in this
situation everyone is no but i uh get
that's what you want yeah okay then
mountain or i didn't feel like they were
enough
so you have a brick trap possibility but
that looks like it's your least option
so do you want a brick for that sheet
i'll take a break bro thank you [ __ ]
salesman at the table
what you're going to want to do
there we go
let's see here
oh yeah i was trying to answer your
questions it was it's something i had to
think on more
because you know i think after something
happens you're just
kind of still taking it in yeah
when i slept on it i think maybe
when you started
telling me how you felt i'm like yeah
that makes sense but then
i said this i'm like they stayed for a
very long time i'm not dead i'll tell
you if they really were there
they would have left a lot
yeah because it went on for like at
least an hour right that conversation
after the tour of the house
yeah so i was like so mean to it but
yeah i mean
he was just like when he's when there's
like a mixed company and there's girls
and guys he'll just be like yeah reminds
me of a little chipmunk
what are you talking about
wow derek dimple
that was a very dark movie yeah that was
extremely a daredevil do you want to
answer the question or do you just want
to freak out what like the question that
you asked
which one what are you exactly
[ __ ] freaked out no i do want to know
that yeah like derek like yeah next
company loud yeah because he he he
caters to the girls yeah and then the
dudes are just sitting like dude you
just like chirped and burped in front of
us like what what are we supposed to do
with that that's silly like you know
it's it's it's
not something that you're supposed to do
in mixed companies
it's
uh
yeah i mean it's like
it's company yeah
and also it's like it's not even good
for a girl like why are you just
listening to this dude make funny noises
like you're not contributing
right right i say it's the confidence
that like whatever he's doing clearly is
on purpose
i don't know bro to five guys guys and
gals yeah
green because he's very good at blue
women with other dudes
brown
yeah yeah
yeah he's like i think he has a lot of
sisters and stuff so he's like a good
like brother he knows the buttons to
push to make someone smile sometimes but
yeah around
but sometimes it's not appropriate to
push those buttons in certain situations
like and he can't help himself he just
has to yeah he's like
for everybody does anyone want to trade
some wheat or brother he's a [ __ ]
devil yeah little brothers are devils a
lot of the time uh
no
don't do it
don't listen to her are you selling ore
i'm selling wheat oh you'd like to give
me some oreos let's go no all right all
right uh
what about for a sheep i'll trade a
wheat for a sheep
okay
am i supposed to see their cards here no
oh uh
i have a yeah you have to wait
gareth no one's talking to you
stop trying to salesman everyone i'm not
salesman anything i'm just trying to
trade all right i'm gonna um buy a
development you can take advantage of me
probably i have no idea
don't say that
do you talk to these people like they i
don't like that i want you to be
competitive they say though
have you been paying attention you know
i'm done great it's your turn bud you
need to know
i've been paying attention okay
no i know i just you need to pick up the
cards whenever you roll yeah
so now you pick up that robber and you
move it somewhere okay yeah this is new
okay primarily it's something that's
going to disrupt hans
[Music]
hans
i haven't pulled anything yet so i have
to pull uh
you know
no no
yeah okay give me some
hey i think
holy crap
unless you don't have hay then i'm
[ __ ] right
i did nothing
do you want to grab it did you hear
about how derek no this one did you hear
about it i just pick any yeah did you
hear about derek booked a show called
santa and his elves
he booked a show called santa himself
and he booked fat comedians and then he
booked skinny comedians and some of
those female comedians were female who
were fat
and he didn't tell them that it was
because they were fat
i'm not going to say they're i was going
to ask their names yeah so isn't that
kind of [ __ ] up doesn't that show that
he's like doesn't really value people he
really cares about himself yeah that's
interesting i had no i mean i wanted to
defend him right now however he also ran
a show unless you want to buy something
that was only black people i don't think
you can and it was him another way it
was like a slave auction or a trade on
these things
yeah and like all the he didn't tell any
of the comments that yeah they all
showed up no that happened yeah i want
to defend them right now but i have to
bring up that fact
yeah if you tell them yeah i mean
i don't like to talk about it [ __ ] up
anymore
it was [ __ ] up dude
we're just objects to him
yeah it's unfortunate
build on this road
okay i'll trust you what are you doing
in new york
just a couple shows hanging out visiting
uh which ones like the standard
it's probably upstairs
that's is that eight yeah
give me that
has there been any nights
i rolled one oh that was the right after
that yeah my lucky number was it six i
think it was not yeah because i gave you
some stuff for that
move the robert steal one resource from
the owner of a settlement
is gareth going to pass out in the
bathroom again
no no hey man we've got pedialites uh
just to let everybody know i
drank a lot of tequila before i came
over here and then we drank a whole
bottle of uh whiskey
this one orange give me a uh
brick please looks like you didn't
finish the job what do you want
what the [ __ ] is that
saleswoman
you [ __ ] up yeah that was the one part
i wanted you to get
stoked okay
are you done
no you put it in front of you
put it in front of you oh
what's up hey what causes you to pull
the shield card oh you buy it are you
done oh you purchased that yeah okay
cool it's the development card
okay got it
don't move it stop
[Music]
where'd it go who's using it
no no don't let this got it up for a
vagina
uh five i need a view i want to borrow
it is it gone you you wrote it you
should grab a resource
they wrote a five so you get a
good
word
feel like i never saw you with the stand
whenever i would go to the store yeah
too quick
i used to go there to just to watch yeah
grant turn them over just stop showing
us your hand keep the regardless just
keep them down okay
we're trying to be competitive here but
do you want to trade for that one
put on the serious stuff no straight up
i mean do you i really i'll give you um
what do you want you know thanks
fans emailing me and today
is
yeah you shouldn't do it hey do you want
to does anybody want to trade for wood i
need wood no
that's fine
for what
i need the brick
i'll give you the brick later
how about that i'll do i'll give you ore
now and i'll give you a brick later i
swear
i swear
write me a brother's
oath as soon as you have a brick
as soon as i get a brick i swear i'll do
it
shake i don't break my words
i'm a man of trust and honor and i'm
going to build a settlement in my turn
okay
so how many of you guys have done anal
with your girls
oh well i mean i had a seven year
relationship so it was a good amount did
you really yes five years two years with
vanessa so after how many years does a
girl open up her ass to you
huh uh only when i was good
okay so how long does it take to
do it yeah well she was a pretty first q
id she just wanted that she was so white
the first date was really good got it
she's uh
she's uh yeah black people don't really
talk about doing anal
no there's really white people that are
starting no i mean i used to be in your
english i don't like it but like i used
to be very against it like i was like as
a kid like when i was like 19 and 23.
okay and then i got into my relationship
but i was like i'll take a break i'll
eat your ass whatever you want it's cool
like
it's all love baby it's all good okay oh
wait why am i taking what i don't have a
building there right
oh i'm gonna take one from you that's
right sam
11. i thought it was oh
thank you for that thank you
don't you think anal is mostly just like
a symbolic thing it's not really about
the feeling you're right
it's like oh i'm putting my penis in
your dirty hole yeah yeah yeah we're
getting dirty too does this also mind
then
if that's right yeah no no no no no only
a settlement what the [ __ ] are you
talking about that's not even your color
no i'm saying because his is on the 11
and i rolled 11 right is this well i
have a i have that's his color
orange
you're blue no the roads don't do
anything we're gonna connect only if you
have a settlement you're right kristy
are you gonna what are you gonna do now
i don't know i'm going to
because i suck because i don't build any
wood
on it's okay
do i take his wood or does he why would
you pick up his wood pick up your
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is an 11. you already
got that right yeah why would you pick
up this one i thought it's like
whoever's on the yeah you're not on this
you're blue not me but like if there's a
competitor on it no no no no no no no no
why would you get no competitors
look okay
so you get 11
here you get a brick because you're blue
right you already got it
okay
he is feeling stressed overwhelmed
slightly
possibly even suicidal especially
uh i rolled those five
so you guys can enjoy it why are you
stressed
are you okay
are you just worn out i think i'm calm
okay
three people are yelling at me so i take
i don't know how to play this game
what a ridiculous what a ridiculous he's
like a gold merchant whatever
do you have a brick yet
what a ridiculous world he lives in
where you can just pick up settlement
resources from
other people's colors
just to make sure i'm trying to ask
before i finish what i'm doing but so
i'm picking up everything that has a
settlement on it right no
no
no
no okay grant listen to me this is a
really we need to tell you about this
simple fact an 11 was rolled
five okay so you get
one oh you get everything that has a
five on it so look this one has a five
on it this one has a five on it so you
pick up whatever if you have the thing
yeah so you know when on elevens roll do
you get a brick when a nines roll do
you're good hey hey when a six is rolled
you get uh a sheep what's yours for his
role you get
i don't remember he got me ut right dude
if you don't know if you don't remember
your sat score
then it wasn't good
it's just we've been playing for at
least like 10 minutes dude you remember
your sat score yeah 21.50 1943
i didn't how did you get at three
oh i don't know
19 40. said
why
i know gareth
maybe it was 1945 is it not threes i
just thought it was like increments of
fives or tens it could be that
1945
but maybe on the essay you got a
specific number are you going to buy
anything
oh no i i finished
you need to i'm doing badly like
sex
oh [ __ ]
anyone want wood
you [ __ ] move this robber yeah for
what
uh
brick
now that had two bricks if she didn't
put that nobody has any breaks oh that's
my [ __ ] brick too no that's true
[ __ ]
who did this
yeah who did this there's no brick i
think i did that
no that was christy oh christy
but i appreciate it because she took it
off my
three oh yeah
thank you the number three
damn it
i am my turn
okay sam here you go
three three three
i'll uh trade someone some wood
anybody want some wood
i'll give you two woods
how about that two woods for a brick
okay it's a solid no from the table
uh
maybe maybe it is
[ __ ] three woods for a brick how
about that
no still no okay
uh what about
for a sheep i'll do a brick for a sheep
i mean a wood for a sheep
i'll do two wood for a sheep
no
shut up
oh sorry
is this entertaining you're right in my
ear please stop that oh my god i'm sorry
well my turn is over uh no one will
trade with me
i am the leper here in this table i
think that's nice
don't take that from me
okay
five all right let's see where our fives
are so
that will be for me i'm guessing i'm
making the right move here
i got two two woods correct i find that
yeah yeah thank you all right the first
correct turn i've taken and i am going
to build a road with that
seeing my
all right
oh yeah
that's progression
well you know what y'all
have educated me and i'm sorry i wasn't
paying interest earlier but i'm gonna
get better all right so um don't buy a
road buy a settlement save up
okay can i recant that move though yeah
yeah
you do recant can you thank you what's
the rule you get on trading and
resources can you four for one four for
one good good
got it are you done
yes i'm sorry drinking a red bullet
uh
yeah
seven you [ __ ]
you chrissy that was great
good job okay
all right
pawns in the same now we have to move
this [ __ ] down the cards good thing
they're all [ __ ]
i don't know
all of it i was gonna trade that in for
uh that's all right
nice wait no do that on that five right
here
yeah
he sold you
no i mean that's a good one
weirdly enough or twice
you're supposed to steal from someone
six really yeah you can steal from bran
or owens too late
no
that's not true can i please have one
only i get rehab privileges apparently
why do you keep looking like
at least let me play the game
we should know that if you move the
robber the robber doesn't just sit there
he robs
can i please have one
so how was that card what did you do so
you could steal
she moved to seven this is the round
three seven and then which means
everyone with eight or more cards has to
lose half and then she gets to see seven
more times six or more it's a little bit
more complicated for me eight or more
eight or more eight what or over seven
or so or more same thing sorry i'm fine
my bad no man you got it now i knew that
very well i just uh uh
hard last couple days
for old gareth it's okay
here we go
anyone want brick
i'll give you a wood for
i noticed you got a brick
yeah i got two bricks oh yes you can yes
you got to trade for something
you got a baby
no no no that was the robbings no you
can't just give someone something you
gotta trade for something you didn't say
anything while we were making the deal i
didn't yeah it was that that i don't
care about the rules you give him
something we actually make what are you
talking about just give me something
give him like your least valuable card
yeah least valuable card you got screwed
on that deal he's hand shook and
everything i didn't know honestly i feel
bad too
baby
it's too hard let's just pretend that we
did it and see what hans does no hans is
gonna get upset just he's always
thinking about this
[Music]
[Laughter]
no this is your fault for not telling us
like what was going on
this tournament is fine now yeah you
have to give him
no because you can you can trade you can
be like two bricks for a hay and he said
yeah i'll give you a [ __ ] and a brick
but you can't trade them to under a
whole different
turn that's not true is that
a true you got to give him a card this
was a historic move yeah you can't do
that you need this card
under the table just do it over the
table just yeah just hand
because that's the rules of the game
like i didn't want to give you a card
but i gave you a card remember when i
gave you a card
and you were like oh i uh whatever
but then i was like here you go and you
stole a card
like dawn sees i did that yeah so now
you have to [ __ ] do that things
taught everything's done they actually
waited me over
because you're like demanding that she
gives me a card it's pretty cool but
at the same time wait it's been my turn
yeah you're gonna have to give me a job
give him a card but i was waiting for
this train this is still yeah i can't
get away with just being hot all the
time
that's not what it is it's a real deal
four not used to anything else i would
love to have a sheep
four
four
all right
four over four i'll get you back how
about this i'll trade you on the next
trade i'll give you two
yeah
i'll do that would be cool yeah uh i'm
gonna also we'll make it even because i
was unaware of the rules and now i feel
like it is
you can shuffle all you want
i'll take that one
that was such a tragedy that might be oh
i thought it was okay
uh because i was like
yeah cuz like i keep getting thirsty i'm
gonna build a settlement thank you for
that house i needed that dude i love you
so what do you think about
the uh austin comedy scene
maybe her sorry darting on youtube
i like it a lot i mean i clearly love it
i go all the time
oh you watch you like watching yeah i've
been watching
comedy ever since i was a kid like uh
ron wyatt was and still kind of my
favorite guys
i like seeing people come up and try new
things
and uh
yeah
well we like having you around you're a
good guy also
um ron white probably my favorite
comedian one of the top three at least
so
he's so good he's just incredible he's
[ __ ] so good everything he does
if there's a tater tot yeah i missed him
all that tater hair stuff
too
oh [ __ ] yeah you're welcome buddy you're
welcome to christy
um
yeah i like his
cadence is the word like his rhythm yeah
correct he says smooth he is i love that
confidence and um
i think the one time i tried it on a mic
that maybe is what i was subconsciously
doing i had a drink in my hand i was
slow to try to not rush myself and
i enjoyed it does it uh is it my turn
yet yeah yeah
this was my strategy gareth
now if there's
you should buy some stuff on your turn
every turn you should try to buy
something yeah i don't have the
materials to buy and you can trade if
you have four of one thing you could
trade four like if you have four wood
you could trade it for like one thing
okay
that was going to give it also you guys
can trade with us and you can trade yeah
yeah this is a bank so if you have four
woods okay you can trade those four wood
for whatever you want thank you for
watching
for one of the things yo does anybody
have an ore and i can give you a brick
or something i'll just give you an orb
for a did you say break okay i'll give
you an orna hay for a brick
and now we are equal did you see that
eight caught wrong
thank you
thank you hugs
hans looks
good i hate you
he's very fair he can't say anything
about him he's fair he's annoyed with me
right now though or yeah
he's shushing me and he's just as much
as he takes away he gives guys
i get to be a dick
does anybody have wood
and for hay
yes do you have any more desire for that
pretty good
okay
be on that note yeah i told hans i was
like i've seen you i've seen a lot of
people but the difference was that um
you correct people but in a way that
makes them better where some people just
talk [ __ ] and doesn't add anything to
the conversation
but you do go around almost just like
you know you observe very intently
you watch
one of these guys okay
what would you like do i like criticize
people a lot no
let me so you one guy was i think
drinking before his
set and you just told him you didn't
like straight up tell them to stop
drinking you just like if you want to
take this seriously you need to
i don't know
yeah well
you know what everyone does this is
well yeah i like to tell people that
they're drinking incorrectly six
what is correctly
drinking
uh
like
not focusing on it just doing it
doing it if it's free
everyone just rock and want wood
um
yeah
rock
oh [ __ ] i'm sorry
because it's gone so yeah
what about brick for rock
good
and then uh
yeah i also met a lot of the people that
are
following what you do and you know they
take you seriously and listen to you and
i like to see
you give advice and then someone
immediately follow it
um and give people opportunities to get
involved i think that's one
criticism
yeah i always fan of that all the
coaches i performed best for
athletically ones that didn't like baby
me they told me the stuff i need to hear
you know
yeah that's what i miss about
like sports
having somebody really yeah
uh you perform in new york a lot you
said
uh sports
i know but um nowadays you're like
performing on stage and you do a lot of
new york shows what i heard
i'm from new york anybody like to trade
uh
i need
a wood
i can give you a wood what do you need i
would like a sheep please i don't have
that
okay
i have no deal i have a uh does anybody
else
for wood well i think that being from
new york also is a great way to grow up
and be headstrong because i think what
we lack over here is the ability to be
decisive that's my biggest weakness at
least is being able to say you know
until and when someone's trying to
impose on you
don't try to please them
yeah in texas everyone's like oh yeah if
you want that then i guess
you should get it 11.
but in new york they're like what no
shut the [ __ ] up i'm getting out of here
oh does anyone want to trade for a brick
yeah
pay for a brick um
nothing okay well i'm gonna do
two for one right and i'm gonna take a
break no it's sheep only
oh uh [ __ ]
that's great
i can do four
for
that so i can do it i can be anything
maybe i don't like katana that much
because it's like whenever a
conversation gets going someone decides
to be like oh look i gotta hate and now
i'm gonna put it right here yeah
we can't talk i know yeah okay i've
known that for a while
well my turn is done that seemed very
pointed at sam it was definitely pointed
at me but i'm gonna ignore it okay
oh you're just saying that's too nice
it's just him
not katan
yeah i mean it happens a lot
katana
brings people together well he separates
what do you guys want you want i'm going
to go fast you want the game to get
distracted
this is going to bring us back well i
mean we've been playing this for a long
time
there's other boards seven
seven seven everybody but they're all
gonna be like a little talky
you know they're all gonna have to grant
suggested cards against humanity before
you guys got here ew
i mean for conversation second yeah no i
don't think we have it today he said he
would bring it or something yeah we
could bring you first talking about the
future
i'm gonna go look for my charger so it's
seven you roll the seven right
i rolled the seven okay so move the
robber did you move the robber no i'm
not sorry i didn't
okay so i move this anywhere
strategically anywhere you want here
heavy where's the crown heavy where's
the head that wears a crown so it makes
basically messes up any pieces around it
whatever settlements are on yeah you can
figure it out dude like why is it so
hard for you
yeah now you can steal from ponds can i
put this on your head and see what it
looks like or is your gel important you
can put it on my head if you want
steal a card from hans
so you can go get his truck everyone
loves grant it's very like uh
it looks suited it looks suitable you
look like a [ __ ] fairy
my coaches were right
dude crowns are fun
all right i feel pretty
it's your turn when you're done just
it is your turn
you want to what get them for you
don't get them the number five oh gotcha
i got you
yes sir okay i got it
yes
she was okay
uh
i think i'm making some progress
understanding would anyone like to trade
me a brick
for hey
oh break for a hay
no thank you
i'll give you a hay hello
could i have a brick please no i don't
know two haze
two a's for one brick
yeah done
okay
it's hanza's turn should we just do the
turn
no we should uh wait and talk about
something how about
um how much uh
time was spent uh on this dallas trip
just uh with was it fun a lot of fun
yeah no i enjoyed it a lot uh grant's
dad or dad uh step dad i don't know
whatever
he's a cool guy he's just a family he's
not related he's my mom's like one of
her best friends yeah
we kept this old man up
until
i don't know like how long
we would arrive at two and start there
so and then three hours later so until
five a.m until five am we just barge
into this 80 year old man's house
and then make him give us a house tour
we're like hey
show us everything in your home
he has all those intricate paintings and
[ __ ] everywhere he has like artwork and
crystal from like different places and
he has all this cool pictures where he's
like his mid not papi that's my daddy
and we live in the paddywoods and he's
got this like really thick southern
colloquialism that's just uh it's very
wholesome and it was enjoyable to be
around him i loved hanging out with him
he was really cool let me hit that dude
but yeah yeah what's that we just came
to an 80 year old's house
i'm honest i'm being honest with you
right now i feel bad about that okay
yeah there's nothing i felt bad about
that however i felt like we gave him
life
he will be telling those stories for a
very long time yeah i know he was really
happy about it
right now i'm sorry
i was just really stoked about him it's
a very cool video i heard that yeah i um
i usually go over to his house and i
just listen to what you all kind of
listen to for a bit
and you know
that's good too
i'll go back to the anal question last
time the only time i did anal uh i was
in high school senior year it was my
girlfriend and uh
we were we were [ __ ] and she was like
she like made me stop she's like oh [ __ ]
and then she went to the bathroom she
came back she was like i didn't [ __ ] i
just like wanted to try it again and
then i was just like it was too much
since she said she had a [ __ ] again and
i was like i don't this isn't for me i'm
not
i don't like this anymore anyone have
rocks yeah and what what not a fan
i like the old no
what did you say raw
rock oh so you're like
you don't want to do it because well
just like much involved yeah just like
it's just like it wasn't hot anymore it
was just like okay i'd rather just
[ __ ] like
you know
it seems really unnecessary it's
bringing the devil into your
business i very don't use christian
allegory that's that that show will make
you schizophrenic yeah yeah
that's true
13 years
christianity
i feel actually
sheep
have had for you
i want sheep sorry
who who brought the oreos that's not you
take it yeah that's mine really yeah
it's the party snack
wow
i should have got the double seven dude
you got the party p like
[Music]
dude you did a good job on the other
people showed thank you like it was i
got nervous like when my date was
shaking and everything
and i was like
give me like
i couldn't handle it after that
you like kept it going
when i was like out of it
well
that's the good thing about that show is
that if one person is like boring or
like getting
a little nervous you can always switch
to whoever is the other person is
there's other people baton class
there's four people on stage
yeah
so it's just
it's like a hang it's like a party it's
like yeah conversation well i asked him
the first question and he like looked at
me and answered and he was like like
just like shaking sweating
and like that immediately i'm i'm
empathetic
i guess so like i immediately got just
as nervous as him
i like the uh show me your nipple strong
because i was start
what does your penis smell like and he
turns and he's like just like it just
feels like i don't know i noticed he
kept looking to hans and uh
molly people like support he was like
what does my penis smell like i don't
know
she asked me a question about what penis
things here
yeah i was really grateful that you guys
picked up the like slash eight
uh yeah he wasn't very uh he got nervous
i think immediately and then followed up
with yeah you guys would ask him other
questions and he'd be like i don't know
give an example of this i can't
then his question was like
how's the walk going
yeah the whole improv of us on a
mountain he's like i can't do it yeah
so yeah does anyone want to trade
a wood
for a sheep
or a hay for a sheep no
oh you have i'll trade a hay for a sheep
i'll take you
hey first sheep yes sir no no i have a
hay oh i'm sorry for your sheep okay
okay well that's my turn ladies and
gentlemen
pass that to
like this crown won't even look
appropriate on you gareth
you don't
you're not fit to wear the
how insulting is that that nobody in
your bloodline has ever been a royal
well you know what what what bubbling
what do you know can you even
distinguish like
here could you put this on your do you
mind i'm not putting that on especially
after all the [ __ ] it just came out
of your [ __ ]
disneyland no because like you put it on
him and you're like oh yeah he could
easily be one of the people in the ferry
you put it on me and it kind of it's
like okay maybe like whatever okay yeah
you're hot and gareth is ugly you put it
no that's not what it is you put it on
gareth and he's just like i just need to
lose 20 pounds of according to
[Music]
like a royal foreign
i'm like a royal
[ __ ] asians don't have crowds they
have like
whatever i'm so sorry
version of it
i made it clear
it was
an cool it's a very nice hat i haven't
been asking for a while yeah that
doesn't look right it just doesn't look
right crowns don't look right is there a
narcissistic thing it looked right it
looked right
that's because you want to [ __ ]
that's not true huh a little bit keep
saying that about everybody well i mean
we all want to [ __ ] each other there's
nothing wrong with that sounds true just
stop insulting us
i'm just saying that like
it looks like in the paintings whatever
like which
like the medieval painters that are all
white and i think it does like it's me
it's like a british thing
but you're irish no what is your full
lineage i'm sure you have something uh
ashkenazi jew from
christie is like trying to convert us
back to feudalism
i'm trying to take us to communism well
i was actually explaining everybody's
queen
yesterday
you watch explained
whose turn was it i saw a chest
it's your turn i think it is
no you already rolled a three yeah i
rolled a three i got to buy stuff i
don't have anything but i mean the idea
of like some people deserve to be kings
and other people
don't deserve to be kings is like how
they maintain power yeah yeah
have you seen that's just the
brainwashing that christie's known
have you seen the episode
no i haven't seen it
because yeah i mean they talk about all
of that because you look the wrong you
should get it it's kind of how running
for president is rather than the
impressions on tv rather than maybe an
iq test that they don't let your ball on
grass 18 11
11. okay thank you appreciate that i
mean the idea of a king was like
very crazy it's like this person's power
deserves everything
and we all deserve nothing and it's it's
good in some way because it everyone is
so damn loyal like they're loyal so i
don't
yeah but it's bad because then it's like
sometimes everyone is loyal to the wrong
person and if that one person is [ __ ]
up then your whole [ __ ] is five four
your [ __ ] is [ __ ] like uh
that that the um roman emperor
or whatever his name was nero yeah
everyone was loyal to him like
six was he one of the bad ones or was he
yeah he was really bad he was super
sadistic and insane
and uh
his congress thought that like everybody
agreed that he sucked but then they were
like no we we like it
well so they all agreed he sucked but
he's like well he does his job well
that's like a lot of managers
yeah there's a lot of managers in like
companies like everyone seems to hate
them but they don't get fired because
they produce results you know does
anyone want to trade a wood i have a
wood i would like a brick
no
also like i'm gonna do this for a shoe
if there's infighting
then people are like i'll vote for trump
even though i don't really want him to
own the libs
so like even though we have a democracy
we can have like a
fascistic dictator because
we all choose to have if the people
choose to be ruled over by a dictator
then
uh then that's what happens how about
one wood and one hay for
we're choosing this a brick i'll give
one wood one hay for one brick
one wood and a hay i'll give a wood and
a hay for one me me me me
two ladies
she has such hot girl mentality that's
not true
it's mine
listen to me
i wanted this song
oh it's your turn and now i can do what
did you learn about kings dude so one of
the one of the interesting things i was
going to say is that uh
it was interesting like for instance the
british empire they enslave everyone
right
yeah and then the countries individually
they cut in
absolute power is the royals right so
they're the ones that are
authorizing the enslaving everyone each
country
fights for independence there's lots of
bloodshed and then when each country
gets independence they have literally
their little government yeah and the
royals of britain go over there and like
change their position into like a
celebrity
so they go over and they're like dude
that was crazy like good job like
congratulations on your independence
like i'm princess like whatever and like
i'm really cute
yeah and then so they like cha they like
pretended that they didn't enslave them
like they pretended that i'm just like a
cute princess
yeah like you guys are so cool like i'm
visiting you yeah and they did that to
all these like 60 countries i was gonna
tell you on the screen someone sailor
green team mentions your other people
video is not uploaded just give you a
heads up
i don't think that's right okay
it's not on the videos and hans kim's
seven yeah yeah
dude check out my instagram dj hanson
go online stories remove the robber and
then it takes a while so seven is the
number seven above blueprint yeah and
then if you have more than seven cards
eight or more you're going to get rid of
them do this
all right honestly i didn't even know
who's coming
do you have any cards you have in your
hand
eight or more because you have to get
rid of that [ __ ] [ __ ]
actually no i did get damn
that's not how many
half of your car you're like
you're like an english king right now
i'm just gorging on cards
but nothing's getting done
my people are suffering classic
so after they won their independence the
king
or the princess would come over and be
like oh hey good job i'm gonna do this
thing and then they would maintain their
power
yeah like that's insane to me like
that's really crazy to think about
but the king and queen represent the
good parts hopefully
not really i mean not if you're the one
that was this is like king leopold of uh
there's no what you got for belgium
exactly the one that was ordering like
all the problems you had
to get rid of and so for him like
imagine if he went to the congo
afterwards and he was like
dude no hanzo he has eleven cards he's
gonna get rid of five or six five he's
gonna get rid of one more okay
king leopold had like a mistress that
was like playing him
and she was like all the effort done
uh i'm done with my turn going all the
african children like getting their
hands chopped off to mine whatever it
was all going to this one woman
who was like [ __ ] the king i want to
bathe in rubber can we make this happen
yeah
yeah
dude i was telling some black people i
was like i think it's the white women
i like i think it's history i think the
white women are in their dresses like
just being like i'm hot
like and they just need all the
resources
yeah it's only having white women in my
family i can tell you they're pretty
[ __ ] shitty uh could i have a wood
for hay please
no
um yeah no yeah you can get about it i'm
sorry misunderstood again but the thing
is like king leopold was already doing
it
i thought you were wood please would who
wants to know there's nothing about it
or anything like that so king leopold
was all these guys want to give you one
king leopold was already [ __ ] over
the congo and this woman was just like
using her social engineering skills to
get all that wealth so she's like the
only person that is like that's someone
decent in the story
apparently i want to see that
how did you see that
behind the bastards it's a podcast by
i forget his name it's his pen name
anyways but he's like this guy in
portland who covered the protest
and he does it behind the bastards and
he does that this is the end which is
like a podcast about what would happen
if we went into a civil war it was super
interesting that sounds crazy that's
cool yeah
what's his name what's his name robert
or something
just look up the podcast for sure for
no [ __ ] yeah four
yeah i would like to know more about
candy apple
i'll send it to you
but uh you get it
yeah i mean he was basically that king
leopold was like autistic
the whole kingdom didn't didn't even
know that was happening it's kind of
like before when you made me give him a
card and that was in just but you're so
autistic christian
by the way you wrote four
you get an award no
you get two well i think kings could
probably do sociopaths
yeah yeah okay good uh
loads of hands and he's like give me
more like he didn't phase him yeah just
like just a corporation i need that
profit to roll in people are nothing
well a lot of them yeah don't deal with
the
the actual blunt force trauma of their
decisions it gets passed down to other
people and then the people who didn't
make the decision have to carry them out
i was telling that to like my roommates
uh ordered the
uh they ordered the elimination of these
rats in our apartment
yeah in new york or is this an awesome
yeah in new york and the eliminator came
in with glue pads which is the worst way
to work
to watch videos of rats getting trapped
in glootress but that's three days
were you looking for solutions for that
or something you have a brick i'll play
you a wood for it yeah yeah dude i came
in and there were babies
why are you watching videos of rats on
[ __ ] blue pads yeah yeah
very primal oh my god like it taps into
something in your head where like i have
a problem and i want to kill these
things remember hobo fights
i didn't like it like the rats were very
cute oh then you wore them
i had to put them all i had to put like
six live baby rats like glued to this
thing in a bag and just put them out in
the freezing cold because it's like it's
pretty terrible yeah and they're they
just starved there
i get what you're talking about dohan's
with the primal thing because like if
you watch like i watched probably the
coolest documentaries
yeah i sacrificed those cards i have
this do you recommend this
settlement first you got to build a city
or you could replace you i say replaces
a settlement but you know what are you
going to say i'll leave it right i'll do
this
there you go
anyway i was talking about uh primal
[ __ ] and like i watched the most epic
uh video on national arnagio like a long
time ago and it's about these [ __ ]
gang of lions that had no other option
for you roll over here except for
elephants so they had to learn how to
hunt the elephants i mean it was just
[ __ ] crazy like washington didn't
have to kill an elephant what does this
have to do with rats and glue traps it's
just that primal tapping into like that
that was some crazy [ __ ] i talked about
a long time ago
i wanna conquer if i had to conquer an
elephant how would i do it i would go
for the legs i would make them jump off
a cliff yeah yeah they push them off
cliffs they had to figure it out and
they had to work like everyone
that's easy that's natural problem
solving yeah but what was crazy is
usually the lions don't hunt they let
the lioness go hunt but they had to all
work together to take down different
parts of the elephant could i have
different parts of the oven please
that's like a abusive husband and an
alcoholic being like fine make me some
[ __ ] dinner i wouldn't do it i'll
cook myself i'll do the vacuuming wood
for or uh no thank you wood for or no
wait you have ore i swear to god
do i do it again
um uh the good thing the thing i liked
about the mouse traps the rat traps and
the glue traps is that that's crazy you
could see how stupid they were oh my god
like they would get one foot no it's
very sticky yeah they would get one foot
stuck they tried to like get and then be
like they tried to move and then they
would trip and then the other foot would
get in the glute then again and they try
and then the
the bad thing is when they fall over
sideways
then they can't move and then they're
facing
and then they soon there's like no part
of their body that can move yeah because
that everything is touching the glutes
my dad and i spent 20 minutes together
trying to get a mouse off together
outside and we couldn't it was like
bleeding like coming here
dude i hate glue traps and so i was
telling my roommates i was like don't
you know if you need to eliminate them
you can do other ways like don't do glue
traps and they were like we don't give a
[ __ ] about rats and i was like that's
hitler like hitler never killed anyone
he only ordered it he didn't care he
didn't personally yeah he didn't
personally do anything so we have to
kill things that's something you can
kill them more sustainably like you
don't have to order them killed in the
worst way um i feel like the same trap
on a human scale would kill so many
people too like i feel like so many
people would end up having that same
rats are intelligent which is the scary
part like i think people would have
having the same kind of reactions that
they found themselves in that because
who expects that
i see people videos all the time
yeah glute people slip on ice knowing
there's ice at their door they like want
to challenge it and see if they can get
through it i feel like with glue people
could think oh it's not that strong and
then they're like
suffocating on it and that's it
i think some people but not as many as
rats i think we would be like oh my
foot's stuck oh wait this stuff that's
the same color as the thing that my foot
is yeah it's probably the same like
people would see that person dead like
i'm gonna probably avoid that
but that's like oh
that's the thing too like there's these
rat trap videos and there's like these
cubby holes and there's cheese inside
the cubby holes so one rat sticks his
head in and then the wire comes up and
chokes it
right there the other the other rat sees
the dead body and he's like oh look a
cheese inside and he sticks his head
into the [ __ ] hole and that's why
and then he gets killed oh yeah and it's
like that's why we're freaked out by
dead bodies or like spooky [ __ ] away
from them yeah if we see a dead body
like
so you don't think squid games could
happen then realistically they seem to
die doing the same thing they didn't
have a choice though they were like yeah
if there's money then all our [ __ ] money
cheese
yeah literally
the only way to get out of that was that
they all like more
they stopped and then they returned
because they all realized it wasn't any
better back home no no oh okay i didn't
see that far
yeah
they went back home then they went back
to the whatever i remember they did the
boat in like episode one and then like
that one crazy guy was the old guy was
like nah dude life's not bad i need the
money
yeah
anyone want rock
for what
we
yes
again
no
one sir
what about wood for wheat
what about brick for a week
sponsored by i shouldn't have did that
i shouldn't i forgot about the [ __ ]
robber
you know what i did see though as far as
those types of videos as i uh
i finally saw
um
hyena a compilation of hyenas eating
other animals alive oh three oh they're
like diminished because dude hyenas have
been my favorite animal and i didn't
think the animals actually did eat each
other alive like that
uh just all these different like reasons
but it kind of it's kind of lame because
comedians often pick them as their
favorites yeah gina hyena did that yeah
why did you uh why did you like uh what
did you see about them eating it alive
well you know joe rogan is always
talking about like look at the you know
this animal eats something alive
yeah and i look at the video and it's
like not really true like the bear the
deer's dead so it's like fine
and i have this like an insane like
you know belief about existence where
like animals kill each other before they
eat each other because they actually
have
morals
yeah like cats do yeah you know they but
cats care cats do it because they want
to show dominance they want to be like i
won like or they just don't want you to
keep fighting but dogs will just start
eating like wild dogs in africa
start eating your [ __ ] yeah
so anyways i didn't know that until i
finally saw this compilation and it was
the worst [ __ ]
anyone wants wood for brook
thank you what about rock
yeah i
mean there was this one where like
six
there's an antelope thing
totally alive
cute okay and the hyena opened up its
belly
and took all of its guts out and it was
just like eating its guts yeah and the
antelope is so alive it just stands up
and tries to walk away and all of its
guts are hanging out
and there's like just a hole in the side
of its belly and the hyena sticks its
head
into the animal and the antelope's just
like standing there
like what the [ __ ] is going on in the in
the highness like nothing he's also
sociopaths apparently dude i saw hyena
like take a rhino's tail off and just
eat it right in front of him and the
rhinoceros
that's why their hides are so thick
like we have such thin skin but like
buffalo their their height's like super
thick you can't climb legit i hate that
dude you playing that hunt
thin or that they're so thick i just
hate the highness damn girl
they have such a casual
this casual idea they don't have any
concern at all if you think that's bad
you should see what we did to the jews
in world war ii
yeah
like there was a buffalo laying down and
the highness just started eating its
butt yeah i saw that yeah i was alive
well the worst way to get eaten alive
ass first i know oh dude that's my
[ __ ] there's so many nerve endings
there yeah yeah very sensitive area yeah
but that's why they need it because
there's uh that's the only place you're
open
yeah vulnerable yeah yeah it's like a
little balloon knot yeah
yeah morgan goes crocodiles drown their
prey and then rip them to pieces that's
moral they drown them first that's what
i'm trying to say
yeah they wouldn't have the water to
help them
and then they just split that's it
game over easy two pieces
it's the crocodile roll or alligator
roll yeah it's definitely put it on
yourself yeah
you're showing me what to do all right i
have my turn six
okay next so
don't you ever tell me how to live my
life
i used to watch videos of uh hog
trapping
hey that's my basketball do you like to
trade
i'll give you a wood for a hay oh
yeah you can literally get in a
helicopter and shoot them with like
that's what i've just told hans and he
said he didn't want to go do that
well i don't want to do it
like he just wants to watch rat traps
bro it's different
i'd rather talk about specific things
that's instead of going to trap hogs
rather than talking about what you want
to do
oh oh well i love
fun i'm done great sir
all right
seven please
if i have a city on it does it change
how much i take two two okay yeah
great
you get three wood total
thank you
the vape
hmm
oh thank you
ah
sorry do you think that i could use the
vape please
may i trouble you for the vape
that's better
that's better pardon me
pardon me please
that's good
so like some of your vapes
have you been to uh renaissance fairs
uh no just that uh what's that place
where you eat
that's the beer hall
no
no the restaurant where you like you get
renaissance show you don't talk about
medieval times medieval times that's it
that's the closest thing yeah
but no um
i think renaissance fairs would be cool
though do they ever have them in austin
they have one outside of austin um
okay
a rodeo is sort of like a renaissance
for reality accents are a little
different but it's a little more in the
future okay
have you been to a rodeo yet here not
here in georgia
soon we should go do some kind of [ __ ]
yeah i was talking to dean about doing
that rodeo uh
comedians on bulls yes
he was saying that you can go ride
[ __ ]
like anyone can do it it's yeah
you just sign a waiver and you can go
ride a bull
but it's bad for you
yeah
he's not healthy so i was drinking it's
bet that's probably doing more long i
bet you're getting
yeah sam castillo got his ribs crushed
yeah
is this your turn really i finished yeah
the ball is stomped on his ribs oh my
god borax says i need a permanent katan
spot on this cast
thanks thanks vorak
pronouncing that okay
a little bit too late i don't know if i
could i don't know if i'd want a
permanent spot on here
no let's get to take a break six
um yeah bull writings well i think like
uh it's crazy that we went from in the
medieval ages from like or uh like in
the renaissance from like leonardo da
vinci and bach and like mozart
to like 1800's america where they're
just like riding out in the prairies and
shooting [ __ ] very different contrast
right it's like it's like we went
backwards
yeah it does seem like well there was
nothing for them to it wasn't as
developed i guess yeah yeah there was
like someone chose that they were like i
don't want that material
it's funny daddy and stifling it's like
we're a generation or a country of
people that chose to be smell bad it was
gross the sewage was in the streets well
we do revert a lot too like i think the
romans took over barbarians middle ages
so we literally flip-flopped and then
renaissance after that we'll probably
have another
flip-flop again
to barbarianism or some [ __ ] there was
these bears uh i forgot they're called
but they were like the 18 foot bears and
they were like all over north america
and i was reading this thing the other
day and it was like
part of the migration took longer for
people to get to north america because
they just kept picking them people off
these [ __ ] 18 foot yeah bears dude
[ __ ] bears dude i saw a picture of well
it was like
i don't know i guess i was okay guys
check out the iron bear on 6th street
imagine going through the woods and
you're just like i think what the [ __ ]
is that it's like
those lights
i don't think they announced they're
coming either i think they're pretty
stealthy about it no they're like sneaky
you can't get away from a bear either
they can run in time and [ __ ]
slap you around slap you silly
let's slap you so super hard you guys
said that shark episode yeah
that's why like when i went hiking for
like a long time before no thank you i
brought it
four to the bank for one but you gotta
wait it's your turn
what about anyone want this for
uh rock or
sheep
or wheat
you know what i will take um you up on
that offer
uh i will take a wheat fourf of war
no this for a week
or a rock or rock or a sheep i have a
sheep i will switch yeah
thank you
someone roll a seven please
uh i need my wheat farm back anyone want
to do it again
don't rock are we
what about
for a brick rock are we
you said leave thomas jefferson out of
this
what about two brave for one
what a second
getting a tube here too
damn you were just
yeah i went hiking for like a long term
hike and i brought a gun that was
specifically to kill bears because i
like thought so far into the bears
but that like
i always had the gun like i was always
like so ready because i thought that at
any turn there'd just be a bear there
what kind of yeah
especially like when they're with their
38 special is like the smallest amount
it's a revolver
i don't think that's going to take out a
bear
the smallest that i needed a small gun
that i could hide easily so you just
want to start basically no that'll
that'll do it if you can hit the heart
i've watched a video of this dude
recently scaring away a charging beer at
it no longer you know yeah the bears
started to approach him and he pulled
out a 44 magnum and he was just like
hey betty hey buddy
he's like talking nice to it at first
and then it kind of approached him he
was like
no
no
then the bear just like was like what
the [ __ ] and he was like you don't wanna
and then the bear just kind of did like
this maneuver and he was like nowhere
nowhere
dude when a bear is flinching at you or
whatever what's it called
trying to watch you yeah
yeah when an embarrassed
pretend like you're hung more than he is
and then he'll respect and move on
basically dude yeah well he only grabbed
the 44 just in case which was cool he
was like i this goes wrong sex toy it's
like well if i can't fight
i was camping in the sequoias once and
we came like we were hiking and uh we
came across this
they were kind of like down the ridge
you could see them it was two cubs and a
mother bear and like i've never been so
scared in my [ __ ] life oh my god
like that's what you don't want to see
like a bear by itself is scary enough
but if you get it around
its cubs
because i found out uh
male bears
if they come across a female bear
they will like try and [ __ ] her but
they'll kill the kids first so that's
why the women bears are so protective to
raise those damn kids
he wants to have an offspring
moving in i'm trying to be a dj yeah
that's pretty crazy i mean
yeah so she basically has to step up
so that's why they're so just like what
they're unreasonably aggressive yeah
they'll fight to the death without
without uh hesitation
ladies
sorry
also like they are able to kill anything
they come across yeah so it's just
better for them when they're when in
doubt just murder yeah when in doubt
[ __ ] rip their heads i don't know if
this guy's waving high or if he's either
i'm gonna get
more food or i'm gonna yeah
or i'm gonna lose some children or my
own life yeah
probably eats the kids too
not the mom no the
the male bear he shows up yeah that's
his goal because he wants to impregnate
her with his own
animals are crazy they don't let things
go to waste lions do the same thing
they're like when they try to take over
a pride they kill all the cubs and then
they
do you guys feel anything when you see
like a hot woman and her son do you feel
when you look at the sun do you like a
little boy like six years old do you
think like
that you're gonna keep
you out there no
depends on the situation you know why
because humans aren't bears and they
don't just [ __ ] you because you kill
their kids but you have like the
dinosaur brain is in there so you like
have like but we also have other [ __ ] in
there like cockroach brain and [ __ ]
emu brain yeah when you turn on the
lights i want to scurry away a wood for
a week yeah but there's so many
different animals in your brain that's
specific
circuit yeah
like the nerds who look like mice
yeah if you killed a woman's kid
she would be really mad at you because
she wouldn't yeah she wouldn't want to
hook up with you afterwards yeah
like oh my kid died i'm so horny here's
the bacon
let's go
we need another one i have benefits i
need to call i rolled an eight i feel
horny again all of a sudden does anyone
want to trade about see my kid dad
gets my [ __ ] wet i rolled at eight
kristy
imagine if that's the only way you could
come as if your kid died there are
people yeah i probably like that
stuff i bet there's some fun does
anybody have a wheat i'll trade a wood
for like mug shots for like worth
they're smiling crazy i'm gonna try i'm
gonna get a development card because i'm
i can't win
without getting lucky at this point
how do i
is that right
okay
are you finishing i am finished with my
turn grant i will pass this to you sir
i've activated my trans card let's go
uh that is a niners
you guys go ahead
you could build at this point or buy if
i have that
oh you know what i will
go ahead and exchange some [ __ ] yeah or
you can do the four first well let's see
i don't have the materials well i'll
show it i do i have a boat
yeah build a road
it's time it's time to progress my
society into new lands maybe pillage
with that road yes
so
if i could ask is it i see hans you
build like around
your whole map here is that like a good
strategy here no no no he's doing that
because he wanted to get more trying to
get somewhere or he was trying to commit
to the longest road to get to 10 as
quickly as possible which is why i cut
him off
but i don't know his secondary strategy
for that because you what you want to do
is build a settlement on that sheet port
because that'll put you in really good
position this one yeah absolutely so i
need to put this here though no no you
need to build a cell okay so i'm already
incapable of doing that so no you can't
do that you have two spaces so you could
build right here yeah i don't have the
materials for it though we'll save for
them okay and we'll do that thank you no
problem
oh my god i thought it was a seven it's
a six
tis a six
um
let's see this
done
dj hans
coming to the stage next
seven
how many cards you got very little
that's fine
well
this is a progressive game
anybody seen any positive news they'd
like to share isn't this on tv
i learned a lot this weekend about
comedy
you should really do your prepared
material instead of a rant
the first opening minute well that was
this weekend yeah that was like a long
time ago that one guy thank you for the
opportunity all the crowd work on friday
the guy that went first it was like he
was like hey everyone come over here i
don't remember his name who today no no
on friday when we were at that street
mic the guy that went first who was like
oh
yeah pakistani yeah he was just like
he was killing the vibe everybody's like
hey everyone come over here we're doing
comedy he did it for like the first
minute and a half and it was like he
thought that that was the situation yeah
it was not that's not actually how she
did
he and then the whole he didn't do any
of his material he kept trying to like
he was like walking back and forth like
like he was performing and just making
people feel uncomfortable uncomfortable
yeah 100
it was not the vibe what's y'all's least
favorite comedy that someone could do
like what do you mean you guys showing
like is there a style that is frowned
upon no i don't think so it's just like
know your crowd like like i got jokes
that i don't do and if there's like no
women in the room or like vice versa
okay well like i have
oh i'm gonna
do my bits now but uh it's frowned upon
yeah no but i mean some jokes don't work
for everybody like for the street mic
thing like nine
i don't know the guy was just making it
uncomfortable for all the passerby the
idea is you want to like say some [ __ ]
and get them interested on their own
yeah not like they hear something big
and you sound desperate
so like no one's gonna be like i want to
listen to this guy beg for me yes and
it's like no sir it's like you're it's
like a homeless person asking you for
money you're just like get away from me
we did tons of sidewalk mics in new york
during the pandemic
that scare people
they said that there was none in austin
sidewalk mike's
interesting
but it was like i liked it dude it was
like such good kind of practice people
lined up to watch like it wasn't a
problem at first
i mean it's the scenario that we
experience every day and i'm like oh if
only i could talk to these people
how do i get them interested like with
girl scout cookies like how do i get
this guy
how do i get this guy i want to get this
thing
once you never move the robber do you
have to move the rover oh [ __ ]
too late right yeah
yeah i think for my job i six
if i had to uh
relate to what comedy's like it's always
trying to come up with something
creative and keep them engaged you've
lost when they start to you know sick
getting
i'll get some distracted from that
uh i'm gonna play this monopoly card and
i would like everyone to give me all of
their ore thank you
thank you sir
thank you thank you
[Music]
you must give me all of your ore i got
nothing bro what you got no war
you only got two you really got no extra
or i thought you were all the ore i'm
pouring up over there
all those but hormones
are very hard to come by
okay well that was lame
i thought i was gonna get like six or so
but all right i'm gonna pass this grant
my turn is over sir you pass it
thank you
anyone no no okay okay
grant is your turn okay
one two three four five six seven eight
all right so that is a seven
okay
lucky number seven again any takers
anybody lucky
so i'm going to move the robber move
that robber please i'll move it to jesus
that about time
no no no yes do that dude
that's where you are you're bad don't
listen to this
do exactly what you want sir
oh you want me to sabotage his name no
it's
he doesn't want you to sabotage him you
can do that or you could have moved it
there but you know from either christie
or gareth mm-hmm okay
actually you want to steal from me i
will take i'm winning
that card so then it maybe was a good
move if you're the one winning yeah
technically hans is also winning we're
tied right now okay
you're in second
are you done um i
will go ahead and purchase something
with my
my valuables
oh nevermind i don't that's in my turn
eight no
what's the roll four
i got four
can anyone give me an ore
for a sheep
i don't know
i'll give you a
nope nevermind
my robber's been moved i will think on
getting
thank you
you're done yeah
come again
eight eight there we go that's what i
need
the unchill
has someone flipped this table before
and anger
i've come close multiple times you just
like hit it hard and it all got screwy
anyone won't we don't trade him right
now
thank you they said that you covered me
up
uh
so it's just about the game now
you don't even interested you're not
covered up when you sit like that
because he's gonna win right now he'll
know if you are
12. whoa
okay
first time that's been rolled i think
it's showing the nipple
well that's a better place for it
i had a good day because i guess that
nipple colored correctly
did you get yeah you should have got
your money back
i saw him i ran him on the road he said
well i think he gave it to me yeah i saw
that and i'm like what the [ __ ] dude
so i saw him on the road i'm like why
didn't you keep the five and he's like
just didn't feel right i'm like
so showing the nipple for free was right
okay he's a very giving person where's
the 12 of 12 no one has it i didn't i
had it right here
oh okay
what are you doing
i'm thinking right now it's true
but
um so what do you think about
uh spider-man no way home
i haven't seen it i want to see it oh
you want me to give you like spoiler
free description no no no no yeah don't
forget anything you're going to go let's
go watch it like alamo
you like
something yeah
let's go yeah i want to see it i want to
see it badly it's been a while let's go
this week came out like a month ago i
want to see the second time for sure
let's go this week sometime i'm down i
was i went to it and then the mall got
quote-unquote shot up that i was at i
remember your
instagram
yeah
it was pandemonium dude it was
legitimate it was it was one of those
mass break-ins where the kids could
break all the windows and steal the
jewelry
[ __ ] suck dude i hope they're all in
jail those
no i didn't get to pizzas the movie i
finished 90 there's 20 minutes left
and then this [ __ ] [ __ ] comes in the
lights cut on there she's like everybody
get out there's an emergency and we're
like what the [ __ ]
i am not on the right mindset and my
friend is crippled and we're all trying
to make a good idea
we're all trying to make a good like i'm
trying to be careful about this but it
was terrifying because everybody was
like there was a shooting
and like everybody had to go out of this
exit but literally everybody was like
hurrying a little bit and yeah and when
everybody was getting in their cars
every because the mall got evacuated
everybody was just acting crazy it was
like everybody was cutting each other
off it was wild and there was a million
situation you didn't see so no i didn't
well when i walked outside there was
literally a million
it would be different
it's like an overactive immune system
for an allergy there's like one little
wrong thing and they're like everything
shut down bloody nose
uh
all right
nothing
but yes let's go see spiderman i'm going
to pay money to go see this movie again
they're going to finish it i'm going to
actually finish this time though no they
didn't give us our money back and then
on top of that the theater was so busy i
ordered concessions they were like i i
ordered like these mac and cheese bites
and some like corn dog bites and it took
them like 20 minutes like i missed all
of the you know trailers beforehand i
was like yo what is going on back here
and they were like oh you're just not
getting your food that's literally what
the guy said to me and i was just like
aren't okay
that's kind of crazy but you're just not
gonna get it yeah that's like my life to
make you a [ __ ] sandwich this is that
isn't that just crazy that's the news
life is so weird
yeah oh you're just not getting your
food yeah yeah your demographic always
likes mac and cheese bites
did well that would look good no was
your uh good with mac and cheeseburgers
pluckers holy macaroni is some of the
best one of the best things i've ever
used we are good at making stupid series
that's for sure eight
let's go but it's it's very uh
entertaining
but yeah i'd like to see that i want to
see the licorice pizza movie paul uh
anderson's film or uh did i say that i
feel like i said that incorrectly
no
no i was combining
names there that's where that anderson
came from though but he made like boogie
nights by four or five incredible
i think
slicker's pizza movie is like 8.0 right
now
uh wes anderson movies are fun to watch
on mushrooms by the way sidebar
okay i can't use colors are always
intriguing take any two resources from
the bank
add them to your hand they can be any
two of the same resources so
cool what's y'all's favorite wes
anderson movie
um
uh moonrise kingdom is pretty cool
except for it gets a little like
pedo
there's like kids kissing and stuff for
sure but like the movie is good
i think this is but i don't know he's
got a bunch of them the
the
hotel one the [ __ ] uh
[ __ ] oh the new one no
oh i know which one the one in the
mountains
yeah uh
hotel something hostile
hotel the
transformation uh
that's all i can't say darjeeling
unlimited
remember no no the aquatic is good too
well the wife aquatic is by far my
favorite yeah out of all of them there's
joe cousteau movie which is just so dope
and chocosta's [ __ ] bill murray yeah
it's just an incredible it's just his f
i think it's his most fun film it
actually has a plot unlike a lot of his
well all of his films have a plot except
for this last movie he made it was just
a bunch of really artistic screenshots
are you trading
i did not like that last movie i watched
it with my mom what was that um what i
didn't see the last one i don't even
remember but you didn't you didn't dig
it oh i did not like it good to know
i've kind of heard that from someone
else as well well it was just like a
really there was just no steady plot
line like the entire time it was
different stories but i like some of
them were interesting but it was just a
lot of really unique artistic viewpoints
that you weren't going to get from
anyone else except for him
but uh yeah no i love the life o'clock
it's like one of my all-time favorites
yeah for sure
i feel like that's like the go-to
everyone says though so i was trying to
think of other ones but i don't know i
would say the uh hotel uh is probably
the go-to for most people it's probably
his highly emotional [ __ ] i think he
wanted an academy to look for that i win
go [ __ ] yourself
well thanks for uh helping me through
this one i think uh i've got a
sorry 75 understanding of it
which is better than look at that no
green
wait wait before you do that uh we're
gonna put matches with matches so they
don't get that's what we did well
there's did you understand rock with
roth right uh yeah that's what i did oh
well i was going to say put these before
you start stacking the other ones that's
all i was saying okay you know what i
mean how did you win odds
you got a victory card
[Music]
let me see the victory
i got lucky that's what i was looking
for i kept buying i just bought another
development i was were you going to win
were you going to get close on the next
turn
gareth
yeah i would have knocked on that next
turn
and i would have tried to go from
victory point yeah you could stack them
i saw it oh wait i lied
yeah you're a lot better this time
uh grant did the second best third best
grant actually did really good like
wait you only had four
i had four wait did you take some away i
think what no we didn't do something oh
no i think i was wrong i think you only
had four points oh when i did the worst
thing no you're tired for last i'll take
it soon sorry
christy can you throw your cards over
here
sorry
that energy drink you should not have
given it to her
tomorrow actually yeah i've been working
on
[Music]
yeah i i just uh finished my projects
that i'm working on so um right now
um
so what do you think about
derek default
my overall take away yeah i i said it to
you a few times i guess i'll just stay
consistent is i kind of just um
i understand a little bit more about who
he is
i
can compare him to one person in
particular
and uh
you know maybe he just has a problem
that can't be solved so you have to do
your best to not
be a dick you just kind of have to
ignore and do not engage and then
eventually
he'll
just walk away you know
it's just so weird that he's that nerdy
and also that horny because usually if
you're that nerdy you're like what is
the point of sex anyways
but like
you also cannot give too much
information but i've said this
with
compromising some other trip i always
see him with groups of girls and i can't
tell he's good with girls yes no dude i
think they're attracted to him because
it's like like whenever a girl's
attracted to like a serial killer you
know like they're like oh i don't know
if i'm this guy's gonna murder me or
[ __ ] me and i'm kind of turned on by
that it's just it doesn't know when to
turn it off when it's someone's
girlfriend or you have a date with you
it's called autism no it's called
sociopathy he thinks that too he
deserves it uh yeah
i i've seen that a couple times
i i wanted to
kind of talk to him and also he's like a
weird looking dude so he has to shoot
his shot all the time it's like just a
numbers game for him
oh yeah i wanted to
but i'm just glad that christy finally
figured out that derek's crazy as [ __ ]
yeah i mean i do have another piece of
data congratulations what
i told you the thing about the like show
this is your mess
[Music]
oh the
the elves the santa and the elephant
yeah that and then the just go into your
show
oh yeah knowing that it's yeah the
stories don't help for sure but it just
it's just kind of sad i mean yeah i i
feel bad for him too like it's gonna
cave in
i don't want to see himself
self-destruct but that's all he's doing
because of his own behavior and that's
no one else's fault but yours if you do
that i just don't like being taken
advantage of i think he's a very
interesting dude and i think he's very
good at some things that he does
i just don't think that he's a very good
person
deep down but
i don't need to talk [ __ ] about him i
was just trying to think of something to
talk about what are you talking about
going so many directions
i need to learn how to
make better audio that's your like audio
panel
no that's just a usb hub
okay so everything is connected that's
the audio storage yeah this is the
microphone hans do you think he's
watching
i mean if he doesn't watch now someone's
going to tell him to watch so yeah
the back of the carbs
i mean
i say worship to his face so i don't
really feel that yeah but
like i said i kind of want to tell him
one-on-one a bit
yeah i mean i don't want to influence
anyone's opinion of him
[Laughter]
i just want to talk about it for my own
sake because but you're you drives me
crazy your opinion holds a lot of power
so you have to
wield power responsibly
i mean i uh i get frustrated with
christy because she just like refuses to
see other people's point of views
sometimes
no okay
um but yeah i mean uh
it was a fun trip i did the headlining
set twice
yeah i don't think it was like as funny
as i could have been because i was like
nervous and i was it was a lot of didn't
psych you out at all or been you've done
this before you were at the same club
but i only did like 25 30 minutes
because i had like seven people on the
show last time
did you did you don't feel psyched out
or were you pretty good to go as far as
yeah
i mean it was just another thing that
was just
so you're able to like contract me down
a little bit but you know
overall you were able to control it was
like not a very big part of it and
a bigger part of it was just me
remembering all those [ __ ] jokes
if i could remember it i think i'd be
unstoppable but then the emotional side
of why am i saying this is this really
funny
what what is the point of me saying all
these jokes then that [ __ ] comes in
just for the record i
i would go to dallas
and do a really good job right before
then
she left the crowd
and i'd like get all the girls excited
what does this mean
whatever
sorry they're like telling me to be
careful
your full hour was really good man i
mean i stayed over for the second one i
thought everybody was into it they
weren't into me they were definitely
thinking a lot
what
they all bought tickets for you like it
sold out for you yeah i mean grant
brought his friends
for me so i don't know
you had other shows where they weren't
there that were people yeah so the first
one was good you had free access
kill tony really helps it's all killed
tony really uh hey trevino did that show
on saturday and he just [ __ ] murdered
that there's two uh completely sold out
shows there
and uh yeah it was a lot of people it
was a lot of people
that like guy kept [ __ ] up that was
terrible
what what guy the white guy oh the like
oh yeah he wasn't there freddie so he
didn't like eddie he didn't lie daddy he
didn't like three or four people so they
brand their set but it wasn't their
fault and then uh and
andrew right um whatever we know from
the guitar yeah
he got he had what's going on he had to
get his stuff cuz are you my friend
is that you
please say this you want to read some of
the chat yeah that'll be fun uh i'm brad
says grant has one friend
total brad there are two friends in
grant right here so you're [ __ ] wrong
yeah
dude news bro
i like grant because you can just say
whatever you want to him and he'll smile
it's uh
it's like a
i don't know if it's a nervous reaction
it could be but
um
with a little i love [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] love me on youtube yeah
it's like
i have a friend uh she has these
she created the bandana during the
pandemic when she lost her job
you know when [ __ ] like that happens and
it was a really cool panda and i
couldn't not buy it
it was uh jack and bo
on instagram
yeah [ __ ] love me
[ __ ] love me and a few other cool
designs i have to check it out again but
there's a lot of other good designs i'm
sure on there
but uh yeah my name is taylor she's a
good person i think she went to florida
but
yeah thank you how's her ass
i'm sure it's doing great do you think
it's weird that
like calling a woman a [ __ ] is like a
bad thing but then we turned it into a
good thing
yeah like you're a bad [ __ ] you're an
awesome like you're a badass [ __ ] yeah
you
words are we need to do that with the f
word that's just
social elliptical
system like we when we for like what is
that i think that's a doug's joke um
where he's like not done from the scene
but incredible famous comedian that i
[ __ ] feel like an ass doug benson uh
no i love doug though that doug uh it's
uh anyway the joke is he's talking about
um well no i want to figure out which
joe this is
um
this is uh he's from new york
um hate doug he hates the yankees he has
a joke about [ __ ] the yankees he was at
skank fest he had a dick on his head
yeah painted
what's this name doug
it's not doug i'm just being a [ __ ]
doug benson dugout oh my hero doug
stanhope no doug stanhope yeah
yeah i didn't even remember his name was
doug
i just remember his full name doug stano
yeah well yeah he's one of my favorites
and he had a great bit and i can't
remember it now because i was like
that's which doug it was like a
whack-a-mole oh the elliptical thing
yeah so uh he [ __ ] has a joke where
he talks about uh how we called
[ __ ] people first stupid like that's
what we had their fir the name for we
call them stupid and then they were
[ __ ] yeah and then they became
special ed
and like and it's just now it's
it's ever evolving
yeah i mean language evolves and i think
it's good that we take this like relic
of the past of how we used to be like
your mother is a [ __ ] and you were the
son of a [ __ ]
and then we turned it into yeah you
[ __ ]
you're my [ __ ]
and uh maybe we should just completely
divorce ourselves from our primitive
past or maybe we could harness our past
and turn it into something awesome
modern
something about our personal past or
like human history past
the word the words history how do you
feel about this keyword now
i wish we could i wish
uh more think [ __ ] is a good word okay
i mean there's gotta be something that
you can use to call asians that denotes
how serious you are
yeah yeah japs
what is the word a lot of them
yeah i was gonna say how do you feel
about the movie grand torino
i mean he's like such a conservative
but he's like this is this is the one
time i'll be nice to him dragon lady
he's got here's the one time i'll be
nice to a minority but you know it's
like my uncle's favorite movie do you
think it redeems him fully or if it's
just
like not enough the fact that he did all
that but then he literally dies to save
him do you think that kind of forgives
or if the [ __ ] is coming
if it wasn't enough uh what oh
uh the movie yeah i mean i think it
shows like
i hate minorities because they're
invading and it's like i don't
understand it but if i get to know them
i'd really like them that's pretty much
all it is isn't it
i uh ricer forgot about that one thanks
salvage d
20.
i mean i think he's a relic of the past
i think the way that he thinks about the
world is not it's the characters so much
since
not sustainable yeah for sure the
character or the actor
both both but i think that uh
there is some wisdom in that old way of
thinking
that we shouldn't throw out the baby
with the bathwater and it's cool to see
that
immortalized you can pick and choose the
good things yeah yeah i think things
were more important to people back in
the day like you didn't waste [ __ ]
that's very much so the the behaviorisms
of our generation how did you get that
shirt back
oh morgan came by the house oh
in the morning yeah she we went to
run an errand and then she messaged me
back that she could drop it off she
hadn't left for fort worth yet so it
wasn't too far away whatever apartment
her friend's at i think
so uh she was really cool
she's really nice i'm sure he'll come to
austin see you soon man
yeah
absolutely nice
it's just so weird because we had our
thing and then it's like i was in a
little mini relationship
oh for that day or oh that weekend
your sweetheart you didn't [ __ ] it up
dude didn't you say she already read she
tested me yeah i just feel like i could
have been nicer and treated or better
yep oh my god what the [ __ ] do you whoa
whoa
i'm just saying like
you're gonna you know you're getting
better every single time right like
you're gonna get better
what the [ __ ]
you're gonna make a mistake it's like
groundhog day you know you do as good as
you can and then you make a mistake and
you start to recover where are you
starting where you are now it's like
this it's up and down um
and some people it's easier to treat
them better
they don't annoy you yeah or they just
are likable people in some way or you
like just match yeah
yeah like gareth and i talked forever
today about all the [ __ ] literally grew
up and did the same things
sorry like there's definitely a
[ __ ] talk for sure we're definitely
talking about [ __ ] for sure you guys
connected
yeah just like i connected with sam um
we were brought together at creek and
cave just sat next to each other and we
were both in the same boat we were
invited to come and we didn't want to we
didn't see a point in sitting alone so
bianca introduced us to yeah well bianca
gave me free tickets that night and then
uh i was sitting and she introduced me
to grant and then
just like we're both sitting two tables
next to each other by ourselves
and then after that we like got along we
just clicked
the same vibe
and bert when he came in and then bert
burr was cool and burst's very personal
uh he's very genuine he tells you
exactly what his situation is and he
doesn't pretend to be someone else
he doesn't does it pretend to be someone
else he knows how his thing doesn't say
things that are embarrassing like
sometimes you got a small dick or
something yeah but
you know i like it because people
like to just talk about themselves
positively yeah it's annoying
and they're not like real people
sometimes they can be they just gotta
[ __ ] he went he went on other people
yeah dating show and then he went on a
date with that girl yeah he
later on he got a kiss from her too yeah
yeah she was he said that she called him
cute and yeah she was hot who was this
which
tour date and then uh i guess they went
back up that's such a television thing
to do yeah but it's so creative well he
had it he had the tickets already he
like came here with a bunch of would you
like a second like
extra tickets he was doing and he just
planned on inviting me so that's just
his personality but who are you texting
i'm uh posting my podcast
you wanna do this podcast right now oh
you're on the podcast
that's funny yeah
not into segways segway's here
segway the city tour and then he took
they went up to his room and then they
made out he said he had the second base
that's awesome
i think we focused too much on her
job i don't know who burt is
california it's about making a
connection
yeah about bert with burton
you gotta be genuinely attracted to
someone too though it can't just be hey
this is it and there you go we gotta
celebrate tiny victories doesn't have to
be you clothes all the way you got
someone to like you enough to trust you
to go out and then kiss you on the face
during a pandemic so i think it's pretty
whatever they're comfortable doing at
that moment maybe that's the best that
they could have done that night because
they were doing they had some [ __ ] going
on in their head yeah you don't know
what's
what's that inside out
yeah have you watched that movie inside
out no
i don't know what's going through his
head or something like that right and
all the emotions and things are going
crazy or wherever they came from before
they met you like i had a date who
walked in emotional first date she just
got into a car wreck
and i was like where do you
start bingo
she's weak yeah it was interesting she
starts you know she's crying a bit and
i'm like hi grant like i hope you're
okay good for her to still go on the
date yeah that's why that's like my uh
the girl tonight on stage dana she
rose the occasion did it i [ __ ] loved
it yeah you know what she sucked or
something no she really tried to sign up
yeah yeah oh cool no she was really
interested she was
halfway created i watched the whole
thing
well no i went to sand drag and did my
thing and then i came back okay yeah
yeah uh there was only one girl that
signed up and then everyone else had to
like force someone to come up yeah one
girl had to do two dates
yeah
i was like what if we did a dominant guy
now and and see if as if see if a guy
could be like lead
me
but i know it's like whatever next do
you want a guy to get up there and just
ask you to show them your name first i
was going to offer to do two dates but i
was like maybe y'all had like maybe that
was enough of me
i told you to stick around when you're
leaving and you said you had to go to
sanjay
because i said yeah i did my senate
saying yeah yeah which is reasonable
reason yeah better to do a set than to
watch why are you saying that it'd be
weird if i did two dates if somebody
else had two dates i didn't say it would
be weird no it's gonna be weird
it's just the beginning of the show it's
better to get more people up there
yeah what um dana said was
it's a lot harder for women it's like
you're literally putting yourself on
stage
you're not prepared for that kind of
lighting on you and you're not prepared
to go on a date it's very tough yeah for
guys too for men what what do you talk
like that's what she said i don't know
they know what they're signing up for i
mean they're going to uh it says it on
the tickets like yeah i don't know if
it's harder for women
right there
i don't think that that's
harder for women there's like a million
things that are kind of harder for women
but like yeah that's not well the truth
is on a date is harder because i mean
all the most richest women are married
to richer dudes like dating for a woman
is like survival yeah but you're also
there
doing it on stage is you're like look
how good i am at dating yeah i think
that is like a big determiner of where
i'm gonna be in life it's kind of a
secret negotiating ship that you're not
supposed to reveal like
yeah you do it in secret and you try to
cajole someone to
marry a
millionaire i mean there's always been
like the last three or so shows there's
been some really cute girls in the crowd
like they're just they're not that
scared are they just
too nervous to get up there or whatever
they're feeding off it's always like
way more men in the bucket like that's
on brand for
the show
i don't care yeah and then secretly
they're like i'm gonna get laid
yeah we gotta sew our seat
no i really didn't give a [ __ ] i'm sorry
i'll be more genuine next time but also
i was not um
into my date
just put it nicely uh today i was yeah i
could tell yeah i wasn't there
you're not supposed to make that obvious
that you're not into your day
that's really hard for me the last date
i did on other people was this like
stoic russian woman and i was not there
was like that rough
the one that went horseback riding or
whatever before that or like
she was a little i wasn't into it but i
didn't get come off that way i was very
personable and tried to include her yeah
i should have done that for
when derek was in the room
yeah and instead of just getting mad at
him i should have been like oh i don't
like you but let's just make this social
situation as good as it can be
well maybe thank you
yeah
no it's you that was the first
impression for me we're talking about
two different things you're talking
about past experiences with you and yeah
derek that's totally
different but i think it's good to
detach from social situations and just
be like i feel a certain way but let's
approach this like a game and try to
obtain the optimal result yeah that's
true that is a good way to i mean it
keeps you out of your like
feelings so to speak and like negative
emotions yeah but then if you get too
far into that you become robotic right
i mean yeah but it's not a bad approach
to just take it you know remove yourself
and just be present instead of like
thinking about the past yeah like oh i'm
not attracted to this person
i hate them let me express that to them
yeah exactly we make sure they are
they're reminded every every sentence
both times that i've had dates on here
like they were both not attractive
but i i've been able to make it kind of
seem like
you find mutual attraction so if one
party isn't attracted it doesn't matter
if you're just dragging them along for
the ride [ __ ] you for doing that and
they're like giving you just giving some
ugly dude hope is that what it's doing
chris
yeah it's a stage thing yeah not on a
real real date
when he showed his nipple like i don't
know he had a smaller nipple
very honorable that he like uh
he lost like 200 pounds recently so he
has like a lot of like the loose skin uh
[Music]
didn't match the 200-pound loss that i
was expecting to see like
this like stretched out areola
yeah
hershey's kiss nipple that's cute
i love that guy what is the old ideal
nipple
hershey's kisses
just like now i like just the perfect
admirer just like a little yeah but it
also has whenever a girl has like those
big ass like yeah like baloney nipples
or like no i'm not going with that big
titties because it has to be
really tiny nipples on like some giant
duties that's weird if it's proportioned
with the ariel whatever what i don't
like is long nipples
like [ __ ] i call them monkey fingers
how many how many girls like in
proportion like have you been with a
girl that has long nipples yeah that's
[ __ ] weird dude it was like oh yeah
don't worry
i'm gonna snap it off or something yeah
do they say anything about it no it was
with this girl i would have to talk
about her nipple was like my pinkies it
was literally like my pinky and she had
really tiny breaths really cold she had
an incredible ass but it was like just
shift focus yeah i want to be like
one of those will move on to
another region i hate that i got a
question i wouldn't do that if because
if it's a proportion but these girls are
young
they haven't had a kid yet no yeah yeah
i think it was like i was
in college i thought we'd get long
nipples after we have a kid because
they're suckling and stretching yeah
messing around but that's droopy yeah
that's true yeah you're tasting the
nipple too i think she wants to because
the milk lands expanding in your breasts
that's what and then they fall down but
if it's just erect then that's something
else yeah kids long nibbles are just
like would you rather have dick sized
nipples or a nipple-sized dick
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i could see a girl like a lesbian girl
like
having sex with another girl's long
nipple oh wow like her dick's like
[ __ ] by a long nipple regardless i'm
always happy to see a titty even if
there's some long nipple way yeah it's
it's something
you saw something now you can share with
the world always grateful for a nice
lady that thinks i'm interesting and
wants to have that exactly it's always
good you the goodies
yeah it's always a good thing it's not
really a bad thing i mean bad dates are
a bad thing
for sure yeah i mean
yikes
i mean what's y'all's worst date as of
recently
uh i went on a date and i it was kind of
going good and then she asked me
if
i wanted to sign a prenup and then if i
would be a stay-at-home dad
and then i started asking questions i
was like well i was like yeah i'll sign
a prenup i guess but then i started
asking questions i was like do i get
like she's like i'll give you an
allowance and i was like okay uh what
are we talking about here and she told
me i couldn't work and i was like
oh and then i said well do we get like
can we get a housekeeper and she was
like no you have to do that i was like
well
what are you talking about here i'm not
trying to
kill my dreams raise the kids and clean
the kitchen
you do everything dude i was like
fetish i'm not into it i wasn't into it
she wants to control a man
yeah that's exactly what it was did she
have a lot of money
not yet she said her parents have a oil
well but like soda mine and yeah
it's not like oil yet so like it goes
through stages it's natural gas and then
it's mud and then it's oil and uh
hers so like one day would be like maybe
she would prosper from having an oil
well so it's like not even like
she's like trying to become a sugar mama
yeah she doesn't have the sugar part not
yet yeah i was just like
no i'm not into this at all it was weird
it was just uncomfortable and then she
was like she was then i asked her i was
like
i i forgot i said something i was like
well
the second date
uh
she was like
i i said well you i'm i'm just not into
you know being a stay-at-home dad and
blah blah you like kind of came on too
quick and she was like well how do you
know i was really wanting you and i was
like you [ __ ]
asked me all these questions i think
that you were just making me make you're
good enough for me yeah well you [ __ ]
good
yeah the fact that exactly it's like
well now you're
weird
you're related to derek is that what
this is are you a sociopath
i think a lot of people are told that
you're the best you're special you're
unique there's nothing wrong with your
god yeah you're never gonna die and then
like we look at other people as just
extras and supporting characters
to our main characters lives and then we
don't treat people
uh like they're separate entities but
like they're objects to improve our
lives
yeah
using
yeah always
so is that how you think of people no
i'm asian
how do you think of people i think of
them as yeah i'm like clingy and i'm
like come on let's be together i want to
be with you
what is that
or is that just being
[Laughter]
when i brought uh derek to the front
door that one time you had i thought you
were about to like [ __ ] karate chop
his [ __ ] head right here so you look
good
you have the most stern like yeah asian
math face that i've ever seen like
you're a [ __ ] algebra or something
you're so mad you're just like
what the [ __ ] you were so [ __ ] bad
dude this is what it is you got that was
the most asian this is what it is you're
an asian man no you're just like he
opens the door and he's murderers
wait i was gonna like act out i mean i
literally that's pretty close like he
got a real agent
in my head
i mean
he just went
he's just like
he's just so mad he just had his whole
show
he's like my nemesis
i did not expect that face to be there
oh no man it was funny it was funny
you're like get the [ __ ] out i was like
all right
it's just like i'm just gonna
swear i was like
what's he doing here because that's the
first reaction i didn't explain and then
i was like he's not welcome here like i
tried to be polite
but um yeah i mean uh like the the house
and the host dynamic and the guest
dynamic is a very sacred one
and it does it's very emotional you're
literally letting someone around all of
your most prized possessions and they
can get you into sleep sleep yeah
stay at your house you can call the cops
and be like this is an unwanted person
so you as a guest you're something
you're lying on here
you're [ __ ] someone comes in your
house in austin it's like good luck
they're going to do what they need to in
the town when you're in your own
property you can literally murder
somebody in the state of texas
that's correct so like legally
everything hinges on your emotional
state towards this person and if i'm not
willing to extend an emotional uh
you know feeling of hospitality then i
shouldn't walk them in
no absolutely not you don't want to put
yourself in that situation
but as it goes uh worst date stories
hans i know you've been on a lot of
dates recently
dude going on a date yeah tell us about
like this
so some of your most some of your more
like wild dates recently wild dates well
the one that i think of right now is
this girl that was kind of overweight
really overweight
and
she would it was this this is only
pokemon go she was she was just like
playing pokemon go
and i was just like over there just like
i could see you were just being
lately
she's like playing pokemon go behind
your back while you're making out with
her like he's talking about i was like
on one corner of her yeah like three
quarters of you on the north side
yeah this could have been a legendary
like yeah no no was she attacking a gym
i mean that's actually like i get that
yeah i think she was just throwing
pokeballs she had
notifications on it
but it's like such a fat mentality to be
unable to control your impulses to be
like i want to play pokemon right now
yeah i kind of have to
look at the back of my phone i just love
them
but when everyone's doing it it was
crazy when it first came out yeah that's
what i do running into people that are
also doing it would be fun no that was
why it was really cool at first i was
just walking around my neighborhood
being like can you
run into a friend and he's doing the
same thing i was like oh that was
[ __ ] sick it was a gold rush
icebreaker for you to meet girls if they
were you know
like can you sell your
catches okay so i saw this video
recently like this chinese guy in new
york and he's on his bicycle and he has
like
30
phones and he's playing pokemon go and
he's just like on all these phones it's
like on his bicycle he's like cruising
around so what's the point of that like
if you can't sell him is he just like
maximizing himself i don't know dude
i never played it uh never mean i mean
that's capitalism it's like you find a
way to like you know play do a lot of it
and like just like you know get really
good at it
let me try to see if i can find this
fast i'm not gonna drag it too long but
i it was just like it was so bizarre to
see this [ __ ]
it was literally like 20 phones and he
had like a stand made and everything on
the front of his bike the first
like bad decision i ever made my wife
like i can go back to it my mom had a
garage sale and she said you can either
sell your pokemon cards or your yu-gi-oh
cards had i kept my pokemon cards i
could have paid through college and i
had like a hundred games turned out it's
[ __ ]
yeah that was literally the first i
could point out that was better to have
loved and lost and to never lose this
man
nice what is the deal like that's what i
don't understand i don't know about
pokemon go obsessed with something
you just want to do a lot of it look at
that look at all those phones here it
looks like the sword like thrown from
game of thrones but with phones it's
like dangerous he has like iphone threes
and iphone 12s they don't discriminate
they all got the job done
i thought it was too but i think the
this is just this guy's in taiwan i saw
one in new york like by times square
it's just the first one that came up
yeah i mean if you have a game and you
want to get good at it you just take it
to the next level like humans are always
doing that it's like we have a it's like
an expertise of taking it to the next
level
yeah like even if we don't want to or
need to
we just take it there greed
but i think there could be a lot more
games like that like geo tagging games
geocaching or whatever that's called
dude um what is it called augmented
reality like i really want them to make
manhattan or like i guess austin
downtown or something into an augmented
reality where you can play like grand
theft auto and stuff
but just like anybody else that's
playing it has like their like name on
top of their head and then you can like
throw a grenade and they like run away
but you can see everything else still
and you could do everything you wanted
to do in society but you couldn't
like you could jump on people you could
like you can address them you gain a
sociopathic confidence to do whatever
you want without consequences like why
is that going on 6th street like i guess
you still can't salvage you can't like
says he was selling the accounts that
makes sense i guess
appreciate it thank you salvaged 20.
what if we just made this world awesome
instead of creating a fake world
because people don't want to put in the
work when they won't see the results
that ends up is what people are too lazy
to do they don't want to do it if it's
not going to immediately benefit them
i'm saying that's a bad thing what about
that pokemon go guy well i bought
virtual real estate recently
did you want to waste
virtual real estate that's taking like
the worst part of reality and the worst
part of virtual reality and combining it
did you see like facebook actually
facebook actually had the like thing
showing you like okay now there's where
you you can put your avatar and it's
like this little sidewalk through a park
okay where like little cartoons are
walking around toontown and that way
like what it is is like anybody who's
live on your message board
is shown walking around
on the sidewalk so you just walk up to
them and say hi and that's like you
messaging them you know have you ever
watched red band's show before his vr
shows
and stuff within vr it's pretty [ __ ]
wild and there's a lot of
joe rogan's podcast that it was just
like the old message boards it's just
people talking to each other yeah and as
a comedian you're already so much
further ahead than most people because
we just talk all the time
practice all the time maybe yes
yeah i guess and most people are in
offices like doing that weird thing
where you're like not really saying what
you're saying
yeah
what do comedians seem to struggle with
the most if they're really high in this
skill is it universal social direction
practical
social
everything becomes like emotional and it
becomes like a meta battle
between people instead of like actually
trying to use conversation as like a
conduit the conversation becomes the
main focus
instead of using it to like fix
something being serious in an elongated
way
like a like a serious couple can like
get very serious and like be all
lovey-dovey for like six hours straight
like hold each other's hands for six
hours
but like if you're a comedian like after
about 30 seconds you're like chill
well we have like a pathological need to
be authentic and then we look for
authenticity even though we don't have
uh there's a difference too when you
like see someone like if you break like
a comic will bring a friend around like
all the comics like unfortunately i do
and they'll try too hard too because
they think oh these people are really
funny like i need to
try to do that and then they can't
replicate that because they're not being
themselves
that's what it's all about is being
authentic
yeah
that's what i was saying about like
social interaction i've seen a lot of
comedians like always trying to do their
bits in like real conversation it's like
you're not
you're not contributing to a
conversation right now you're like
trying to make me laugh and it's out of
contact yeah you know what you're
talking about selfish behavior where
you're just trying to get practice on
someone and don't value it yeah person
you're just looking at them as like a
binary like yeah approval disapproval
punching them be a real person i don't
really want to talk
like i would just rather not talk to you
if you're not going to be like
oh my gosh contributing
like just like be a normal person don't
like try to like yeah i don't know
that's all keep it on the stage yeah
well not i mean whatever like
no just be a [ __ ] normal person like
i'm funny we're all funny and content
like in conversation so i can't ask you
about like a new idea no absolutely you
can't but like don't like control the
conversation and make you sit through
yourself
right that's the most important thing is
like gotta let the other person control
the conversation yeah well i [ __ ]
hate doing bit my bits with [ __ ]
random people i especially hate it when
since i've been doing comedy and i tell
people i do call me they come up to me
and they're like oh you do comedy tell
me a joke and i'm like hey come to my
show yeah how about that i have a show
on the 10th i'm not your [ __ ] jester
i tell people some jokes sometimes when
i say that but
i don't know yeah they struggle to
realize usually if i tell them a joke
it's not like it's one of my favorite
jokes it's not going to be a joke of
mine and i'll tell them i won't be a
dick like that but that's how i feel i
have a double good ones that i
say
to people that like
i can still do my set and it won't give
things away i don't know
[Music]
but
what do you call two [ __ ] and a
[ __ ]
a mistake wait what
yeah what is it i don't know
[Music]
oh wait what is it that's actually
that's good
ch word
what do you call tooth maggots and a
[ __ ] a bit like what and you just say
c-h-i-n-c-h wait why did you just spell
it
you just misspelled it changed
that's the thing about non-comedians is
that they don't go for it their whole
thing is like they don't want to go too
far
but with a comedian we're always trying
to go too far
yeah i think yeah regular people they
just
i mean if they don't know you and
they're coming up to you they're
expecting maybe like hey how's the
weather like really base conversations
and then you end up giving an extreme
answer and they're like that's a that's
scary and they walk away but there's
also great regular people like you
you know grant like you've done a couple
of months but you're a person that we
like to hang around with regardless just
because you're a genuine person you're
being authentic you're talking like it's
not hard to be authentic it's just that
we live in such a world that causes us
to be authentic or mechanical that we
throw ourselves out of the conversation
yeah into our own minds
yeah that's we should hang out with
comedians more because that would make
us healthier wait really yeah because
then you'd practice being authentic
instead of like just using your
personality to work in an office
you're saying to practice being genuine
with other comedians other people should
hang out what was that oh oh okay the
guy that did eddie's second show neil um
what's his face i care where he had a
great joke he's like i love how they
were writing the amendment and they're
like all right [ __ ] first thing i can
say whatever the [ __ ] i want he's just
like yeah because that's what it's about
dude it's about authenticity i want to
go through show queen he's a great
comedian neil um degrasse tyson no
i admire that
amanda that was his last name he was
great if um i could respond what you
said so i really appreciate that first
of all but i also really like hanging
out with comedians because you have no
filter and i'm surrounded in an
environment where everybody's very
careful with what they say oh
i have a filter me at work is a
completely different character when we
hang out my interactions with you
are right genuine and unfiltered we can
talk about whatever but when i live at
home do zoom meetings and talk to these
people i feel like everything can and
will be held against me you know either
corporate like espionage type [ __ ] or
they have a bad opinion of you and you
kind of just stick to safety but in this
community
you you should listen a lot to what they
say because i think comedians want to be
heard yeah but also like have genuine
things to say back and
be nice overall i hope so [ __ ]
literally i think being hurt is the
biggest thing
for a comic in general it's a weird
thing dave chappelle i think one of the
things he said that i really resonate
with is
like
i don't know it's a weird image like you
you want to do that people come up to
you and be like oh you have balls like i
can't believe you would go up there and
say yeah i don't really have like oh
why do you have giant clappers but it's
like it's not that it's the fact that
there's this is what whatever
people [ __ ] say that they do dude he
just looks like a turtle that like
doesn't have a shell
i don't know i [ __ ] are you talking
about me i mean he no
he's not really here
oh no dave yeah i like how he's like so
calm and poised and he does that ron
white
yes
but i think like when he was younger he
was more like
she was sharper yeah
dude i i watched the chappelle show and
like yeah the first and second episode
are good don't you [ __ ] talk anything
i'm done
maybe it's in an age though first and
second episode of good and then after
that he's just like i like titties and
the rest of it is just
so we've got grace
i mean that like literally every single
episode is funny there's not any [ __ ]
he's not even there i think there's a
lot of fluff in it yeah the first time
it was so good
i know what it was
that moment in time it really spoke to
that generation but i mean how many
times like do people re-watch
chappelle's [ __ ] i rewatched it and it's
just like
i like titties that's a white woman i
like her but it never goes viral like
it's not even like any genius
yeah clips do not like on youtube or tic
toc they use like his voice
everybody's just you don't see that but
like it's not as popular as some other
[ __ ] that's true i mean he's being
attacked right well i feel like he's
used to it
he used to be more viral you know like
back before and then i think it really
just like gave him a legendary status
whenever he walked away from 50 million
and then like
yeah no one heard about him from eight
years people still knew about him but
then he comes back and he's like this
[ __ ] still this powerhouse with like
this wisdom but like
still funny and still you know do i look
like a controversial of his like latest
stuff like maybe that's making me be
like oh his old stuff wasn't that good
either
but um yeah i mean it just seems like
it it was kind of like airy it wasn't
like very solid like his sketches it was
just sort of like a feeling and an idea
a
loose idea
sorry
what was so funny uh he's he just sucks
and like i guess
i don't know what to do about it i don't
know i hate you so much you have to like
i don't know like we have to
like you're never going to need dave
chappelle yeah everybody's going to be
always meeting him he's going to be
amazing like when when he goes on stage
and the way he can control the room yeah
like that's a skill for sure and he's
really good at that well if i ever meet
him yeah submitting submitting
the masses to a bad idea
like hitler like hitler dude he's
hypnotizing yeah he uses the fewest
number of words possible
he's such a genius do you think dave
chappelle would pick dick-sized nipples
or a nipple-sized dick he would rock
with excise nipples
you already told stories about uh your
bad dates right no we haven't gotten to
art wait he did i did i told him great
yeah it was a bad date you're really
attracted dude man
you think 25. y'all got to make fun of
me
he is the golden retreat did he just get
like [ __ ] just come up to him want to
pet him
yeah
but sometimes yeah i'll tell you the
issue with that you know um
sometimes
especially like with the catfish
scenario i you know i'm a little bit too
trusting like a golden retriever too
yeah i'll ride with you let's go
um i was on a dating app a couple years
ago
and uh you know the images are i
probably could have done better betting
the prospect but eventually you know i
was dumb enough to say like hey we could
come back to my place eat a pizza watch
a movie it was like around valentine's
day and we didn't have dates so
i i had her come over and as soon as she
got out of the car i could see from
hundreds of meters away that she was not
at all who she presented
even if
i have to say i i immediately even if it
was like your
just the dishonesty alone would be
enough for me to be like
immediately unattracted but then of
course she was unattractive because
she's trying to hide that and you know i
still like stuck to it
[Laughter]
she came in 45 minutes
into your house yeah
people
you know like when you get on stage with
someone you're trying to get away with
it they don't even yeah they're gonna
get caught
i should have been immediately but she
came so far i felt obligated like this
recent situation where i'm like i just
this is my grave i gotta lay in it
i didn't go so far sleeping with her but
it was very awkward for like a couple
hours we
i ordered the pizza already it was ready
it was a heart-shaped domino's pizza
oh my god
and we were watching some
the thing was like you're such a you're
such a bad boy aren't you great yeah
heart-shaped pizza that'll bring her in
yeah you're going all out you're being
like
laying on your back showing your belly
basically even though i was definitely
upset but i should have showed it but we
i put on a good movie so i actually
liked it and paid attention i think that
was how i
that's how i got out of it i was just
showing the the disinterest and but i
still you know
spent a couple hours fed her i felt like
that was like
you know a lot of dates end up like that
well as long as they you know eat it's
like well at least i accomplished a
little bit and like i didn't have a
terrible time i didn't i wasn't
disrespectful to her asked her the same
questions i just focused more on the
movie and by the end of it i'm like well
that's the end uh all right i'll clean
up and you learn anything from this
yeah don't invite them to your house
maybe yeah exactly
that is a public place yeah always meet
at a public place and always
make sure you like add them on a social
media or something yeah even then you
can picture
catfish that's not enough but i think
yeah you can definitely this public
place i was hammered the other day at
like 1am and then this girl hit me up on
tinder and she's like hey let's hang out
what are you doing and then uh i was
like hey let for sure and then two
o'clock was covered i was telling her
we're at the bar and it seemed like
everything was going great and she was
like all right um you know you should
just uh i'll come down there i'll meet
up with you i've just been known me uh
20 bucks or uh yeah and i was like okay
no problem
and then immediately nothing
like oh actually like
number got changed or was it
probably dude but i was hammer drunk and
i was just like that [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] got me so bad
right now
that's full-time tender tindering that's
amazing
yeah just have to you can do that but i
mean you might get banned from dinner it
would be yeah yeah they have some way
they'd do it
i had a really i'd rather not do that it
sounds seems like a bad job it's like a
bad mojo yeah he's gotta come full
circle people and things like that yeah
it's like a deer like you know how like
when they're elk hunting they go they do
it they look like they're called
yeah that's that's a catfish the version
of the cabbage
massive level we're all about deception
these days
white is what it seems until you see it
in person and still even what you see in
person they can tell you a story and
deceive you well people are just crazy
one time this guy came up to me and he
was like hey i'll give you 200 or give
me 200 i'll give you all the answers to
this test when i was in college i was
like [ __ ] you i can actually get an a on
this desk or i need to cheat and then he
texted me like a couple of days later he
was like if you don't give me the 200
i'm gonna tell like uh you know your
professor that you cheated and you're
gonna cheat and all this other [ __ ] and
i was like
i'm gonna [ __ ] i was like uh if you do
that i will literally murder you
like i will [ __ ] kill you dude it's
like if you want to [ __ ] start some
[ __ ] like that dude you need to know i'm
gonna [ __ ] end your life man i was
like i'm not [ __ ] around here i will
beat the [ __ ] out of you dude like don't
[ __ ] try and crazy [ __ ] like people
are doing something he tries to [ __ ]
with your life
dude most of the time you gotta have
something full of [ __ ] though they're
like just trying to like they're just
they're trying to use your
scaredness
to their advantage i mean call them
bluff dude like so because like that's
easy for you to go talk to your
professor and be like dude look i have
these text messages yeah exactly i was
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
i would like do it i just i believe that
just take the emotion out of it be like
[ __ ] you go for it well what was worse
is it was a guy i knew in class
uh he actually uh solicited me a test i
have the evidence to prove it would you
like to see why is he signing up for
school to get like 200 bucks here and
there
yeah it's way more expensive tuition
yeah well i guess he was covering his
tuition by like getting kids to get or
to give them their answers but that is
this our school system is corrupt so for
sure no it makes complete sense that
this guy is uh feeling that corruption
and trying to 100 dude [ __ ] the system
yeah
but he's just [ __ ] other people right
are doing them oh for sure man
absolutely and then he's blackmailing
people like i can't imagine i'm sure
somebody did that and then he just
blackmailed them after that about the
text messages
are just like taking the testing like
somebody probably did that was desperate
and then he blacks something i saw
as far as like text message manipulation
like now i don't trust what people show
me about texts and screenshots i knew a
guy who
this is kind of how friendships end
right here he's like hey can you text me
real quick something like he calls me
and says hey can you text me this like
message like hey when are you coming
over like
where are we meeting up tonight man like
something like a friend would say when
you're about to meet up i'm like why
would i send that yeah and he's like oh
it's for my my girlfriend i'm like
that's [ __ ]
you're literally going to call me and
have me create a false narrative pull me
in
and then we both suffer the consequences
when she will eventually find out that
you were not with me
yeah why are we at in time for this
podcast right now how long is it going
two and a half hours all right
have you seen that one video where
this guy a girl calls us
her boyfriend's friend with her
boyfriend right next to him i was like
yeah hey uh john said that he was with
you are you guys hanging out
uh yeah
he pretends to be john too
i saw that that's a good friend right
there though i think that might be fake
but it was still a good idea i don't
know if it's a sketch it is a good
sketch though but because he like
he like gives this like stupidly obvious
faithful list he's like i gotta go back
and he like hangs up and they're like
they're dying my boyfriend is like
laughing and she's laughing yeah have
you seen the fake airplane videos where
they have like people fighting on planes
and it's they're now have sets to set up
yes it's [ __ ] insane to me i'm like
wait wait are you talking you know pop
it got really popular these plane fights
like delta when the guy got dragged off
now on facebook you just scroll and you
see like these fake fights play out on
what looks like a plane the angles like
you see the chairs the cub the cupboards
above them the coverage
the overhead compartment compartment
the woman breastfeeding the cat that was
[ __ ] great
those are just the guy's just freaking
out he's like dope dude [ __ ] you like
there's a cat in there and the other
guy's like
they're like no show me the cat she's
like i'm not gonna
do it
but then if it's not a real cat they
have no reason to be mad like you're
allowed to have a bundle of cloth in
your arm that's all over like la even
like influencers are trying to like take
pictures in their private jet but it's
like a studio the same way as the fake
plane yeah and you can like it's like a
real
market people will [ __ ] pay you like
if you have a warehouse and you set it
up like fake you know fake scene fight
or whatever 2.0 people will pay you just
to go use your yeah i thought i
recognized that comic though like the
dude that was like no [ __ ] that that is
a cat like i thought that was a comedian
right when i first saw the video yeah it
was but it was that was a great sketch
yeah i mean uh a lot of our lives are
just like a thing to impress other
people
we're not actually doing anything with
their lives that actually like produces
any results so the only thing you can
get is like the appearance of success
so that's that's the currency instead of
actually doing something
you just want to appear like you're
you're doing awesome things and you're
having the most pleasure possible
well you're also making money too but
that's the thing is like that 300
i made for my first show at the creek in
a cave i'm gonna frame that check dude
like that that three hundred dollars
felt better than any money i ever made
because i [ __ ] loved
what i did that time i was like oh i had
a good show people like legitimately
enjoyed it and it was something that i
made like this was me and like that was
really [ __ ] tight man so we can't
wait to keep doing it yeah did you
accept like in this scenario would you
accept like a million dollars to bomb in
front of a million people like a dollar
ahead
dude i'd give a [ __ ] the first time i
ever did comedy i did comedy on kill
tony and it did not go well
i'll tell you what it was a band we'll
do it for free man
bad
i couldn't even spit out a word i had no
prepared material i had no idea what i
was going to do never done an open mic
i've done like three open mics before
that but it was six months prior but
eliminating
future opportunities you know if it goes
really like that bad like you say a
racist thing or something well i knew
not to do that i'm not gonna go up there
and just start you know dropping racial
slurs i had a little bit better insight
to do that i just couldn't i didn't have
any jokes the thing is is comedy is work
like you have to go and try your
material out all the time you have to go
every [ __ ] day and you have to go to
like one or two or three open mics and
then you know like what i've learned at
this last show hey do your open or your
material that works first if you do a
show and then get into whatever if you
have the time and win that audio there's
just things that you learn constantly or
that i'm learning constantly
and comedy is just an ever evolving
thing like i'm sure hans is still
learning stuff too and he's just
climbing the ladder it's like everywhere
every with comedy they're like finding
out yeah and you were just going up for
your first time
just doing your most basic
whatever thing and i killed tony
oh yeah i had nothing i literally had
nothing the end of my set i was like you
know what [ __ ] fart and that was like
the one thing oh
no
well that got a bunch of laughs even red
man started laughing
and tony was like well red van like that
but that was [ __ ] terrible
and then he was like so you're gonna
kill somebody that my set was just
terrible so you still earned their
respect regardless just for help
in fact i went back the next week and
then i got on again
and uh tim dillon was on and uh i might
as well just taking a [ __ ] on the stage
like that would have been a better what
did tim dylan say to you he thought i
was a psychopath and um so did tony and
i was trying to explain myself and tony
was like shut the [ __ ] up shut shut your
[ __ ] mouth here just shut your
[ __ ] mouth and i was like oh [ __ ]
like i know i was in trouble and he was
like you've never done in comedy you've
come here twice in a row he's like for
the love of god
don't come back for at least six months
go do open minds figure it out do your
[ __ ]
then come back and get on and that's
what i've been doing ever since crazy
when you first do comedy it's a
completely different thing yeah
i'm living through it man first time i
did comedy i had this like two page
story i wrote and i try to like remember
it and then like
it didn't work at all so i told like
that was like i never did it like that
again and then you know
then i
yeah the word for work yeah you're
trying to like
yeah it's like
learn your set like know what you're
going to talk about and then like that
way you can riff a little bit and like
go with the flow instead of like
oh wait i missed the sentence and then
you're like all thrown off you're like
you're skipping around you're like
i don't know never mind that's my time
yeah that was my mistake my first time
but i learned real quick and i never did
it again i'm i don't know i'm pretty
comfortable on like in front of people
though because i've like done acting in
theater since i was five and
not the same as comedy but uh
definitely there's a there's a level of
being a comedian that like you there's
that you gotta get comfortable on stage
too yeah that's a thing so i have that
i'm
i'm thankful for
but it's kind of weird because the play
that you're putting on is a dude just
standing there mm-hmm
this is really [ __ ] funny that he
brings this up grant's mom told us about
her favorite comedian and it's this guy
we couldn't figure it out but she could
remember the name of the show
and it was called like caveman defending
something i'll figure it out again
that's what their pressure
no
and it was the one
okay it's the longest running single man
or uh show done by a comic on broadway
but the comedian that started it made it
he doesn't have a wikipedia page but the
show does
it's really weird
yeah
i don't know what is this wikipedia
is it the caveman defending comedy
defending the caveman is what this
special is oh
i heard of that and yeah i had too
yeah i mean comedy is great
should we uh wrap it up yeah i'm done
here i got to take it you try to do
three hours or something
no i just just feeling it i don't really
care about the time i mean grant seems
like he's kind of tired i don't have the
energy you guys have it's incredible
dude
yeah i guess it's not effective
yeah
i just feel like everyone our community
would be better if there was more money
trickling down gareth from texas follow
it that's the only vlog i'm going to do
i don't care you'll see me if you like
me you'll follow me or not
sam
appreciate y'all having me great listen
play the game and attempt to play it
anyway